hey
everybody it's us again uh hopefully oh
[ __ ] it's lagging again
we're gonna have to i was watching this
video because like i actually do try to
improve this [ __ ] is ramshackle as it
sometimes it looks really dark too
yeah why does it look so dark that's
strange that one is that that light
isn't on up there
oh yeah why isn't it oh did i forget to
plug it in
yeah i guess you did or pookie oh i
don't think pookie unplugs it even
though she was up here fiddle farting
around
there you go well that's much better
there you go not better well [ __ ] i just
i recorded a video like earlier like for
another thing it's like i didn't even
notice it
no it came out okay it was it was
atmospheric that's what i'm gonna that's
how i'm gonna
play it i'm just gonna see how how much
this [ __ ] lags
yeah i was reading i was watching a
video the other day and they were saying
well
nine times out of ten like when live
streaming is
uh lagging it's because you're using
wi-fi you're actually technically
supposed to plug the ethernet
cable into the laptop
or the computer and i'm just like
really uh do we need a cable so
yeah i think i got one out in the garage
somewhere there's probably one somewhere
or like in a drawer in my office i don't
know we'll figure it out
i don't even know i don't think we have
one long enough like to go together no
it's long
oh yeah if i if it's still out there if
i didn't throw it away then
it's long yeah cause we had a [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] computer [ __ ] out there where
well yeah because we didn't need it
anymore because it was from like [ __ ]
the mid-2000s or some [ __ ]
yeah there may there may be there may be
a box of some old stuff still out there
i mean
in the bottom drawer of this desk right
here there is like a bag
that just has like some random cords and
[ __ ] so there might be one in there i
don't really remember
it might help but hopefully it won't
bother people too much i'm just
like i said i can't you know you usually
i'm like
looking at most like on the screen so i
don't do anything like
spazzy or anything or if like my hair
gets [ __ ] up or i have a booger or
something
so it's like i don't yeah well you know
[ __ ] happens
um you know don't i don't know do you
know what i did earlier
speaking of like having stupid [ __ ] on
your face this this is how
um nothing that i ever do like goes
correctly like for some reason i could
like make a mess like
anything i was painting my [ __ ]
fingernails this morning
right because they you know they were
all chipped and whatnot so i paint them
this morning
i thought they were kind of dry so you
know how you kind of like wave your
hands like that like to dry
the nail polish so apparently this nail
polish was so [ __ ] wet
that it like fleck and it got like all
over my [ __ ] face so i have red nail
polish
like splattered all over my face like
blood stains and i was like really
really that's how my day was going like
earlier
the day went fine i'm just saying
[Laughter]
all right today today is gonna be a um a
good sci-fi
[ __ ] this is a fun show
well it's just kind of like we have had
this guy
has been uh recommended like by a lot of
people
and we talked about him a little bit
when we talked about aleister crowley
um maybe we might have talked about him
a little bit we talked about like
scientology and elrond hubbard and stuff
because there's like some kind of
intersection going on there but a lot of
people said oh please you need to do a
show about jack parsons
and i knew a little bit about him but
not a shit-ton so like i started
researching him and this guy is super
fascinating
he's a fascinating fascinating person an
occult rocket scientist
yeah yeah kind of crazy but in a fun way
yeah he knew a lot of people he knew uh
anton levay
he knew uh [ __ ] l ron hubbard
and uh elrond hubbard [ __ ] him out of
money yeah and out of his wife i think
uh yes yeah yeah and then uh well his
girl i guess it was his girlfriend i
don't remember
yeah they were trying to bring out you
know they were trying to bring extra
dimensional beings into the world
[ __ ]
like you do i think um i think jack
parsons even blew himself
up didn't he he did yeah yeah yeah all
right
we're gonna get into that there's like
some conspiracy theories yeah
i don't know rocket fuel i don't know if
i buy them well he blew up a lot of
things
um not always on purpose but the the
thing about him though is like he always
he struck me as one he's like a mad
genius type of person he's just like one
of those people who's just
so out of his own time and he's just
like so out there
but sometimes you kind of need that like
to because he was like way ahead of his
time like what the [ __ ] i mean when he
first started
talking about sending men to the moon
like rockets to the moon
this was like back in the early 20th
century when that was still
like science fiction like even the
government was like [ __ ] that's crazy
no one's gonna go to the moon what are
you talking about yeah and it's like it
didn't even take as long so
he was like way ahead of his time but he
was also
kind of a lunatic but not in a bad way
like in a way that
i would have probably liked to hang out
with him type of way because he seemed
like a fun dude
i'm just saying brown and all them guys
he knew that yeah he corresponded with
them yeah and
uh like about this about science even
though he was very i mean jack parsons
was very very very
very anti-nazi yeah they were trying
they were talking about going to the
moon though
too and putting up with it putting up um
uh
space stations and [ __ ] they were
talking about that all the way in the
late 30s
yeah they knew about it it's just that
most people couldn't accept it as a
reality
there was only like cutting-edge guys
understood that yeah you could
you could leave you know the earth's
gravitational pull and put [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] orbit yeah
definitely about that it's just that the
average person did it's weird
they were like i said they're kind of
ahead of their time yeah it just seemed
to to normal people it just seemed like
science fiction like it seemed like a
crazy idea so if you were talking about
it like people just thought you were
a nutcase you know what i mean yeah i
was kind of laughing earlier
like because before but just right
before we went live and thomas carlyle
made the
made the uh comment up there it's like
that he watched santa sangria this
morning and he felt like his brain was
fried
because i just put the review for that
up yesterday
i got part of the way through it you
know until i started giving i gave up
on it he's like this is too weird
[Laughter]
i liked it for about 15 minutes it's
kind of like watching a musical or
something
or a play it just got weirder and
weirder and weirder and i was like
man [ __ ] this
there's only so much a man can take you
know what i'm talking about
there's only so much man only so much
weirdness
he has a weirdness quota a weirdness
yeah
once he reaches it and it's not very
it's a you know if it was like a bottle
it would only be like that
big and then like once it gets over and
then it flows in yes
it depends on what it is it's it depends
it depends on what it was
you know what i mean yeah in that
particular case i was just
now
[Laughter]
it's kind of like watching a salvador
dali movie
well yeah well he was a big influence
alejandro okay yeah yeah he was really
into dolly and all the
absurdist and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so he
was like really into that theme yeah
um so you can see like that influence
yeah although like i said the movie does
actually make sense there is like a
story and [ __ ] it's not like it's just a
bunch of random images
well yeah i mean it's just that it gets
the point where i don't care
you know oracle says tom's tolerance for
weird versus his tolerance for booze
oh yeah exactly well what it is is that
my tolerance of weird starts it starts
getting where i don't care
what about what the message is you know
what i mean i feel like they're just
taking the piss and you know what i mean
i'm like all right you got me you know i
gotta go
it's kind of like i've been you know
bamboozled into watching it
it's what i feel like like they're
[ __ ] with me you know
no one's [ __ ] you won you got me i
watched it
you know i watched 15 minutes of it yeah
that seems like a really
funny that's how i take it i mean the
movie is like from 1989
no one's actively [ __ ] with you i
know that
it's like a mod well the thing about
well the thing about movies though is
that
you can watch them or not so it's not
like anyone's trying to like force you
to watch that i know yeah
you know what i mean so i walk away from
it when it starts going right i like
that i would have liked to see
i would have liked to have seen his
version of dune though well everybody
wanted to see that
because that would have been crazy pants
probably would have made me mad also
though
not like the movie made me mad though i
didn't really get mad it's just that i
felt like i was wasting my time
i didn't think that the message was
important that's what i thought
yeah i don't even know if i'd so much
call it a message is this like the theme
yeah well like i said i just i just
can't take it
you know you can't take it well the one
well the
the movie that we're doing for the next
retrospective
we've already seen it and i know you
like it although some people said
some people said that they couldn't
handle color from a color from outer
space
the color out of space the color out of
space yeah that's not even that weird
that wasn't that weird
i mean i was just i've seen way weirder
i was rolling with it
you know i was like and then mandy
that's like i thought you know mandy's
kind of weird but
i [ __ ] like that one that's what i
mean it's like i don't know i just i
have a high tolerance for weird movies
and i've seen like really really really
bizarre movies so it's like something
like mandy or something like that while
weird doesn't strike me as like all that
weird
well when you understand lsd mandy isn't
that weird
well it's not weird at all it's about
weaponized lsd that's one of the
characters
so you know that the you know that that
you're tripping when you're watching
this movie
yeah and you go okay yeah i understand
what's going on
i liked it yeah yeah even if i even if i
didn't have experience with lsd i would
probably still have liked it though
it's a good movie because you don't i
mean i i used to like surrealist movies
like even before
i had ever done it wasn't that surreal
it's just kind of a hallucination
a horror hallucination yeah and it was
mostly like a visual
yeah kind of thing yeah it made sense
though yeah it totally did well like i
said it was just a revenge story i mean
it was very
the plot was very simple yeah so let's
do some
shout outs yeah shall we yeah they're
thanking us for the shirts
oh good i'm glad you guys like uh have
got them i
saw i got pictures and stuff like that
from some people that said that they had
got them already
um they've all i think they've all been
sent out at this point right yeah
they're all out
um but you know some people might have
got them yet though yes
i'm sure like because a lot of like
people in the u.s have got them but i
don't know how long the
the international stuff is going to take
because i know i had a whole bunch going
to the uk and i think i'd wanted to go
to australia as well
so we'll see how that goes just let me
know if you get them because
you know all right so uh let's see who
we have a new patron
this week i think i mentioned him on
one of the matinee shows but he i
haven't mentioned him on the main show
yet
so uh welcome darren thank you very much
for your support
also wanted to give another thank you to
louie and to sophie
for sending us a whole bunch of movies
yeah uh we got a whole yeah a whole
bunch of blueberries 15
15 movies we have a whole stack like in
front of their tv that we gotta get
there
yeah they're all good ones too yeah i
know and like well and the thing is too
it's like
i try to watch them but it's like
there's all i you know i try to watch
stuff from the matinee show too because
other night i had to watch well i didn't
have to watch i wanted to watch it
but the thing we're gonna be reviewing
tomorrow the documentary
yeah so i had to watch that and i'm
going to tell you right now the
documentary is like more than five hours
long and i sat there and watched
everything i couldn't handle it every
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i liked it but it was just one
sitting yeah because that's just how it
should have been in three parts
i think we'll talk i didn't i didn't
have i didn't have trouble watching
through the whole thing at all because
but you know i find that stuff really
interesting so um also
my uh short story collection hopeful
monsters
the first edition of that came out in
2009 but i just recently did a second
edition
um and i added four stories to it
and it is out now in all formats print
format
ebook format and audiobook format i
finally finally
did an audiobook version of it which i
had never done before i also have
some free codes for the audio book
i think i have 25 of them um
so if you want one it's going to be
first come first serve
you probably should email me or contact
me
on facebook or instagram or something
like that
if you want one of the codes um i'm not
sure
i think i don't know if they work
overseas
because i know that like some people
from the uk and stuff like that had
had problems like they had to
you know they had to make like a us
audible account
like for to use it so i'm not real sure
like i don't know like i have to look at
the
codes because some of them might work
for uk i'm not really sure if they've
sorted that out by now
because that's like a pain in the ass
but um i'll just i'll try and figure it
out but if you want one just email me or
contact me on
social media and uh we'll try to sort
that out like i said i think i only have
25 of them so
it's going to be first come first serve
uh also
my card decks which i think i showed
before
uh it's four different card decks edgar
allan poe
um ancient egypt ancient greek and i did
like art nouveau
absence looking ones those are now
available on the game crafter
it's under my uh my account which is
called giallo games
which i'm probably going to change up
because most of the games that i
designed at first were
giallo based but now i'm kind of like
doing other like broader horror games
and stuff as well so i might change the
name but
i don't know but it's still under giallo
games at the moment
also i wanted to mention and i think i
might have mentioned this before
i am going to start doing a weekly
horror book review i'll probably put
them up on thursdays
i'm not sure when i'm going to start
putting them up i actually recorded the
first one
today but i wanted to get like a few
ahead
because like i said i want to make sure
that i have time to like read the books
and
you know have them come because i
ordered like a [ __ ] ton of books and i
have
like kindle unlimited account so i can
there's like a [ __ ] ton of books on
there that i want to have this huge list
so i have like a already have a year's
worth of [ __ ] books that i want to
review
but i'll let you guys know when i'm
going to start putting them up but i
did do the first one today and i'm kind
of excited about it because i'm
wanting to get back into reading some
horror fiction so that'll be fun
all right so you want to start talking
about jack parsons
yeah let me talk about that oh thomas
carlyle says is tusk a film
yeah yes yeah
it's a film made by uh kevin smith
yeah of clerk's fame
and um that's an exciting movie man
yeah it it's a love it or hate it i will
say that i loved it i thought
i liked it a lot yeah but i think it's
best
to go into it not knowing anything no no
no because i didn't know anything about
it when i watched it all i knew was the
title and that a friend of ours
recommended it was like you need to see
that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up
so i watched it so i had no idea where
it was going it was a weird aspect
and like i said how you feel about it is
gonna
i don't know i guess that's true of any
movie how you feel about it's gonna
depend on like how you feel about
certain
i don't know it's it's a very strange
strange movie i haven't seen the
i haven't seen yoga hosers um
what's that that's like kevin smith's
other movie that he made before tusk
okay it's not they're not really like
related
exactly they're kind of like a loose
trilogy i think he's making one that's
like supposed to be the third one in the
trilogy called i think it's called moose
jaw or something like that
but i don't know if that one's done yet
but yeah tusk is super weird i'll have
to watch yoga hosers one of these days
even though i've heard
that it's really really bad so i don't
really i don't know
dusk isn't a bad movie it's a good movie
it's just i like it
but it's really weird yeah it's [ __ ]
pretty disoriented because you run into
some crazy [ __ ] for the weird
ideas
weird idea that he makes a reality yeah
that's all that's all we're gonna say
yeah
we should do a review of it once i liked
it too
after i got done with it i was like man
that was really [ __ ] up yeah
yeah well the end of it like really kind
of upset me because i could kind of feel
i mean it's a it's ridiculous but then
if you think about it
you're just kind of like oh [ __ ] it's
kind of like one of those things
remember when we were talking about
when we reviewed return of the living
dead and i was like
it's a ridiculous movie it's a horror
comedy but if you think about the
premise behind it that like the zombies
can still
feel what it's like to be dead yeah i
mean i'm like that's really
existentially
disturbing like if you think about it
even though it's just like a goofy
movie with lemay quickly being naked in
it yeah you know what i mean so this is
she was actually the best part of the
movie two well that's what everybody
says
she's [ __ ] just hot and that was like
at
her [ __ ] optimal hotness yeah
yeah well and also she even wearing
pants i don't think she was
no what i think they ended up doing
though was i think they made her
like essentially a plastic barbie crotch
okay
um because i guess they were offended i
mean this is the 80s so everyone still
had pubic hair
yeah um but i guess they didn't want to
show pubic hair for whatever reason
because she didn't give a [ __ ]
right but i think they made her like
this weird molded because i think she
was talking so she did have clothes on
kind of
sort of sort of sort of it didn't look
like it
yeah but you know she would get she was
in silent night deadly night you know
she got with the tits and she got like
impaled on the antlers and
yeah she was in [ __ ] uh night of the
demons right where she was like in that
pink dress and she's like leaning over
with her butt sticking out in the
convenience store she was very and
sticking the lipstick in her tit and
sorority babes in the slimeball bowl of
rama
you know what i mean so all right so
let's talk about jack parsons now jack
parsons
yes now you're ready to start the show
well why yes
why are you not rather quitting no go
ahead
well it's just it just reminded me it
just reminded me of like some other kind
of stuff that we were talking you know
how we do
yep we just kind of go off on tangents
everybody's here many 33 people in there
okay this is
this is why the show ends up being three
or four hours long
man i don't know if i can handle four
hours tonight it's [ __ ] hot as hell
in here too man
well and also it's maybe 78 degrees but
to me that's [ __ ] hot
floored indoors and the [ __ ] ac is
[ __ ] just jamming
but outside it's got to be over 100
degrees and it's all [ __ ] humid and
there's a damn
coming we had to go to the liquor store
like earlier and it was just like
stupid hot it was stupid hot outside and
i don't
know i mean that hurricane
i think we're only just gonna get the
edge of it right last i checked
but i mean it's still probably gonna
suck it's still sunny outside right now
i do not mind heat but i can't stand
heat and humidity
and that's all it is here it's [ __ ]
terrible yeah it's just like eternal
swamp ass
yeah i don't know why anyone would want
to live here i don't know why i really
don't
okay i don't it's terrible yeah it's an
accident
and i well yeah well for me for me it
was because i was born here
right i was just i don't know any better
i don't know
well i do because i've been other places
and i was just like oh this is much
nicer
i don't have to like walk around damp
all the time
that [ __ ] sucks so yeah
so jack parsons was a very he's probably
one of the most
influential i mean easily one of the
most influential rocket scientists right
i mean he's one of the founders of the
jet propulsion laboratory for christ's
sake
um even though i feel like he's probably
not
as well known as maybe he should be
maybe um i think what ended up happening
because it was a book
that came out about him called strange
angel
and that came out in uh to i want to say
2014 maybe it was earlier than that
and they started working on a series
like a fictionalized series like about
his life
and it kind of went nowhere but then cbs
all access got it
so it's so it went it ran for two
seasons
like so they had a show like about him
so maybe like his
you know cultural impact has gotten like
a lot larger
he's probably one of the most and
and i think that he's well known too
because
of his writings about um
felima you know aleister crowley's
saying and
maybe his association with not not
scientology but
with l ron hubbard like before l ron
hubbard started scientology
kind of thing like because they were all
hanging out back then we're all i know
my granddad knew him
before we get into this just going to
tell the audience in case you guys don't
know
my mother's father my granddad on my
mom's side
was an aerospace aeronautical engineer
he worked for all those damn companies
mcdonald douglas grumman aerospace
general atomics he worked for all of
them
he worked on the [ __ ] saturn project
and everything he uh [ __ ] when he was
working for grumman
he uh also helped help to design the
fuel injection system than the [ __ ]
turbine system for the [ __ ] engine in
the f-14
tomcat got set to iran to train the
shah's men on how to dam his air force
on how to maintain that engine
but he had my granddad been through all
these [ __ ]
air aerospace and aeronautical companies
during that time
he worked he worked on a saturn project
explosive bolts
systems and everything for the [ __ ]
saturn v rocket the heavy lifting rocket
he worked on [ __ ] [ __ ] for his
[ __ ] general atomics [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
damn atomic [ __ ] rocket that they
were making
what was that thing called orion worked
out a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] a lot of it i
don't know about a lot of it i just
heard about it through my uncle
you know because he didn't talk um
and it was a different time back then
those dudes were wild
they were weird and jack parsons
probably one of the wildest
of them all but like i said in a way my
granddad if he knew this guy wouldn't
have liked him my granddad even though
he was [ __ ] kind of weird
he was a religious fanatic which which
is part of the weirdness
yeah that to me is weirder than yeah he
was making rockets but he wouldn't allow
[ __ ] television in the house because
it was a tool of the devil
okay now that's crazy yeah [ __ ] nuts
i mean
as weird as some of jack parsons [ __ ] is
because it's like you know yes he was a
rocket scientist yes he was a genius
in making propellants and making the
like you know a lot of the chemical
stuff he was like into that like
developing rocket fuels and stuff yeah
um
it's weird because it seemed like he had
this like genius
scientific um you know kind
of bent yeah but then he also from a
very early age
he wasn't interested in like traditional
religion at all and it doesn't seem like
his family was particularly religious
yeah but he was always very interested
in
the occult and in magic and even when he
was a kid
you know he would say he would try to
summon the devil and like all that kind
of stuff
so it was like he i think he considered
it like two sides of the same coin
yeah like we're going outside of the
bounds of
human understanding like from a
scientific standpoint and also from a
spiritual standpoint i feel like that's
kind of how he was coming at it well it
was a different time back then
yeah that too and another thing is is
that
it was a scene they were all government
contractors
and you got your job based on what
what project you had already done you
know what i mean
yeah so you moved from one contractor to
the to the next you know
and it was groups of friends in a big
scene shifting around to they all knew
each other
and um it was a different time no
computers they worked with slide rules
they went to school all right like for
aeronautical engineering and engineering
and chemistry they went to school for
that
yeah but you couldn't go to school to
learn how to make a damn spacecraft for
an atomic bomb you had to make that [ __ ]
yeah because no one was doing it
no one was doing it so it was a scene a
lot like hot rodders
guys would go and [ __ ] just take an
engine and start [ __ ] with it make a
hot rod
you know well they were doing this with
the with [ __ ] company money and
trying to
sell these ideas to the government they
had huge budgets
and they had access to [ __ ] other people
couldn't have like nuclear materials
that are [ __ ]
hypergolic [ __ ] rocket fuels
and they had ranges where they could do
all this [ __ ] it was they were like cut
and loose a bunch of kids
who were real smart yeah blowing [ __ ] up
and making [ __ ] go boom
and making [ __ ] go really fast and they
[ __ ] love the [ __ ]
and a lot of it was done at the bar
they'd go the bar
and [ __ ] talk about [ __ ] get drunk
[ __ ] write it down on napkins and
[ __ ] and
and then burn the napkin when they're
going to bathroom and set the napkin on
fire so nobody else can see the theorems
and [ __ ]
because that's like some secret [ __ ]
yeah talk about nuclear propulsion and
next
nuclear external combustion engines and
[ __ ]
and uh it was a different time so
these were not conventional people they
were [ __ ] wild
yeah they were crazy and i mean i kind
of geniuses but crazy
yeah well those two things often go hand
in hand
i mean let's be honest about it i i kind
of feel like you have to be
kind of crazy to think that far outside
of the box yeah
you know what i mean and if you were to
look at my granddad
you know regret grand grandpa weems
that's what i call him
and he was crampy weems yeah and he was
just this [ __ ] kind of nerdy
part syrian looking guy [ __ ] with a
damn
white shirt white short sleeve shirt a
tie big old cook bottle glasses that's
what that's and they all look like that
i was gonna say everybody looked like
that all up until the 50s or
actually until the mid 60s they look
right out of something out of one of
them damn saturn five [ __ ]
programs at mission control yeah you
know right mission control
it's just like rows of like yeah generic
white there's all of us right
with the big glasses yeah shirts yeah
yeah but that's what they were like yeah
and they uh
they drank a bit and they evidently
chased women and [ __ ]
they were you they were toxic toxically
masculine they were yeah
yeah well that was just the way it was
and they were [ __ ] well they were
allowed to get away with it
well they could do it well it was just a
different time yeah that's what i mean
and the the expectations were different
yeah and uh
they uh they were under lots of pressure
uh but they didn't realize they were
under a lot of pressure they just
thought that was normal they worked
they worked kind of hard kind of like
the japanese yeah where they just worked
all every day and every [ __ ] night
they were like that but yeah i the thing
that i've
always found me interested that i always
found interesting about jack parsons and
like about other people of his ilk i
guess
was that i mean these were he [ __ ]
loved
rockets man that's like all even for me
as a when he was a little kid
it's like he would read like all those
old sci-fi magazines and stuff we can
really do this [ __ ]
and it's like he would have his little
friends over and they would like try to
build
rockets and like in the backyard and
like blow [ __ ] up in the backyard
and he was just like so into it and so
hyper focused
on that that you know he did kind of
shitty in school and
even though he was a genius because he
was just so focused on this one
particular goal
which you know he did actually end up uh
you know achieving so
that's something but yeah let's okay so
he's actually
uh his name is not actually jack parsons
his birth name
this is fantastic is marvel
whiteside parsons marvel that's pretty
cool yeah
well that was his dad's name as well so
he was named after his dad
marvel side marvel white side so i guess
that's what they called him until
like after his parents divorce because
his parents divorced not too long after
he was born
and um so i guess the mom was kind of
over the name
she's like oh i named my kid after this
[ __ ]
and now because the dad much like uh
jack parsons would be later on
dad was a little bit of a horned dog
yeah like he got in trouble for
banging hookers pretty much that was all
the time they were doing that a lot
back then those days though yeah but
like think the wives were still not down
with it though no because she was like
no bye they were they would go to
casinos and [ __ ] show girls and
[ __ ]
ladies of the evening and [ __ ] they had
strippers and stuff you know
they had a different way of looking at
it i don't think that
i don't think the dating scene had
happened yet because there wasn't a
sexual revolution
trail it hadn't happened yet so there
was a lot of damn
pent up dudes and then there were
[ __ ] women capitalizing off of it
yeah you know selling it but then you
know the 60s happened so you know it all
became for free
[Laughter]
but you had to go out there and earn it
yeah you know i mean you had to talk
your way into it
but back then they just they just paid
for it
yeah that's my understanding i guess
that was the culture of the time
you're dealing with something a place
more like japan
yeah back then but yeah so so jack
parsons was actually so that's
what he ended up like i guess his mom
called him john but uh all his friends
called him jack
so he was actually born in 1914 in los
angeles
now his parents were actually uh pretty
well off
but uh as i said his parents divorced
like not too long after
he was born uh his uh his dad like
joined the military and like married
someone else and they had a kid
and so jack had a half brother although
he only met him one time
now um they ended up like moving
to like his mom and uh
you know his the rest of his family they
ended up moving to
this place in california that's called
millionaire's mile
so they had money like if you you know
they weren't poor
so he had like when he was growing up he
had servants and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
now like most kids of his
predilections i guess and you have to
think this is very early in the
20th century you know 1914 he was born
so this is like 1920s when he's
kind of a kid um he didn't have a lot of
friends he was very
uh bookish very solitary
um and he was really into reading like
he really liked
king arthur he really liked you know
mythology and all that kind of stuff
um and then he started reading jules
verne and he got really
into um sci-fi and rockets and then so
he started reading like amazing stories
and started thinking that maybe
they could really go to the moon where
they could you know build a rocket that
could really go to the moon one day and
that kind of became an overarching
you know belief that he had and he that
kind of became like his hyper focus
so he starts going to uh junior high
and as i said even though he was a
genius i don't think anyone would
dispute that
um he didn't do very well in school now
you see this a lot like particularly
with these really really intelligent
kids because they're so hyper focused on
the one thing that they're interested in
that they can't be bothered with like
other [ __ ]
and that seems like what happened to him
some of his biographers think he might
have been dyslexic
but i don't really know i don't know if
there's any way of knowing that like
after all this time
but uh ironically it seems very weird
because when he was a kid
he kind of got bullied a lot because
like i said he was very quiet he was
very
solitary he was into sci-fi which was
very nerdy back then
um and he was perceived as effeminate
um even though later on he was like very
macho like i reacted very macho when he
grew up
so when he was when he was a kid though
like he got beat up a lot for being
girly or whatever you know
so he ends up making friends with this
other kid
named edward foreman who was um
a poor kid so he was like from the wrong
side of the tracks but he was
also really really into sci-fi which i
imagine a lot of people weren't back
though like now it's normal but
i think it was a subculture it was like
and it was probably a very very small
subculture i would think and like i said
it's it's still considered
kind of nerdy nowadays but back then it
was probably like super super it was
like some [ __ ] mcfly would be
into right that yeah that's what i'm
saying so i i kind of like am feeling
that that's
about what's going on now foreman
apparently
he um was a lot better read
than jack parsons was like he had read a
lot more sci-fi and a lot more like
classic literature and stuff and jack
parsons was really into that so they
developed a really close friendship and
they started a like a little
group and they apparently
they adapted uh the they adopted the
latin motto
per aspera ad astra through hardship to
the stars
that's they started saying that about
themselves and then they started
making rockets and making gunpowder and
[ __ ] like that in their backyards and
basically
they would either go in the parsons
home's backyard or they would go out to
um arroyo's seiko canyon and would
basically like blow [ __ ] up
and they were trying to make like model
rockets and they were trying to like
make them like go higher and higher and
higher and they were doing like
different formulations and
yeah trying to work out here's here's
the deal today we live in a world where
rockets are something that
go into space or there's weapons you
know intercontinental ballistic missiles
but in the days that they're talking
about here rockets were just toys just
kids made them yeah they were not
weapons
the military really didn't have much
interest in them
because they were feeble compared to
what a cannon could do
so there was no reason to weaponize a
rocket
at this era in the 30s after world war
one
the only people interested in rocketry
as a weapon
would have been the germans yeah because
the germans were limited they couldn't
have artillery they couldn't have all
kinds of [ __ ]
by by the treaty of uh treaty versailles
i think it was called right yeah
yeah yeah they weren't allowed to have
any of that so they were secretly trying
to weaponize rockets
and that's why the germans were so ahead
in rocketry
because they were kind of forced to use
rockets because they didn't have any
other avenues they didn't have any other
other avenue of making any kind of
weapons and rockets were always like
second or third best compared to cannons
so i can't
[ __ ] far outstrip a rocket in those
days
so but then later on you know when
people saw what a rocket could do
rockets became top priority like oh [ __ ]
why didn't we start working on those a
long time we took all those german
rocket scientists including vendor von
braun we got we got them over here in
the united states
an operation paperclip and i know some
[ __ ] about
verner von braun too some one of my
dad's friends
ended up being kind of a bodyguard to
uh to werner von braun when he was in
the uh army
um because he was living in louisiana
like we don't know that vernonville
brown lived in louisiana
there was a special rock a special
secret rocketry research base in
mississippi
they had him living in slidell though
but my dad knew the guy
and uh heard some stories about verner
do that guy
anyway go ahead what did werner get up
to
he was an [ __ ] evidently
[Laughter]
he treated his guards his go he was
always under guard
because they didn't want to run it off
well yeah all right but he treated his
guards as his servants
like they were his drivers yeah he's one
of those guys
uh he saw americans as like third class
citizens
um he had real hot girlfriends
um well you know no shame in that game
and ardent nazi ardent nazi this whole
thing okay well so that's
this whole that's a problem this whole
thing about werner von braun not really
being in with all that nazi [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
according to people that knew him no
he's an art nazi
which is funny because i don't know if
jack parsons ever met him in person but
he did correspond with him
even though like i said jack parsons was
very very yeah i mean he was
adamantly against the knife he was like
more he was very leftist he was very
against the nazis
so uh so i don't know if they talked
about i think
both mostly they just talked about
rocket science you see
later on verner von braun was in charge
of [ __ ] you know
he he was in charge of the american
rocketry program
you couldn't tell the american people
that he was [ __ ]
he was a nazi okay well yeah that might
have been a little upsetting that's
inevitable
so what they did was they kind of
finally he had good
pr they were saying well he was never
really a nazi he was never really agreed
with any of that stuff
um yeah he's like just keep he's on he's
on our side type of deal
no not really uh a [ __ ]
vernafuck there is some [ __ ] you could
say he was that he didn't agree with
everything that the nazis were doing
he thought the nazis were stupid when it
came to how they were using rockets
um he didn't really agree too much with
certain things that hitler did he didn't
he didn't think much of hitler but he
loved nazism
i guess that's good big difference you
know what i mean he liked that party
uh but you know what i mean he just
didn't think it was managed right
that's that's what you know he he's a
national socialist
that's like [ __ ] hilarious yeah
i mean hilarious like you know you gotta
laugh or you're gonna well
no he was a national socialist and he he
you know
he believed in all all that stuff he
just didn't think it was
run the right way well you put me in
charge yeah you know i will not see the
[ __ ] out of this [ __ ] but yeah it all
depends on how you
his interpretation of it you know what i
mean was not
say hitler's interpretation yeah he
would have done the things that hitler
did
but he liked the nazi party of deadly
even though he disagreed with certain
things that it did
yeah but mostly we're talking about i
don't think it had much to do with
you know i don't know what his opinions
were on a jews or anything you know what
i mean but i think
a lot of the disagreement was what what
germany was doing with the war against
russia and rockets that's really i think
what he was mostly talking about
right but
you know yeah whatever
very much so yeah so all right so
um so jack parsons like i said
he's kind of like at this point in his
life when he's kind of like right before
he went to high school
he's been blowing [ __ ] up with his
friend in the backyard they've been
working on rockets
he also again like i said from an early
age
not only interested in rocket science
but also interested in the occult
apparently when he was a kid he
uh kind of performed a ritual where he
was trying to summon the devil oh thank
you very much
thank you very much yeah somebody said
iron sky i still need to like we still
need to review that [ __ ] [ __ ]
um but yeah so he apparently
did this ritual to summon the devil and
i guess
he thought that it worked or he later
claimed that he thought that it worked
and it like freaked him out
and so he decided he wasn't going to do
it anymore
so i like i said it's very strange and i
think that people
um you know think that it's one or the
other like people that are really
scientific minded whatever don't believe
in like a cult kind of [ __ ] but that's
not necessarily the case like people are
a lot more complex
yeah than they seem to be yeah my
granddad made a good
example [ __ ] you know he was involved
in all that same [ __ ]
but he was big into the [ __ ] bible he
could sit
and and he evidently did not stumble
upon christ's
myth theory so how smart could he have
been well i don't really feel like that
was because when i started reading about
mythicism like in maybe the late 90s
yeah it was very fringe i think i got
like a couple books from like american
atheists or something because i
because i was in that and they had like
a couple of like
you know very very small press books
about that so it was like seemed like it
was a very fringe idea
yeah even up until the 2000s yeah you
know
well i know one thing man he could do
[ __ ] advanced mathematics in his head
and use things on [ __ ] and just use a
slide rule
yeah they were smart they're real good
with numbers yeah
and they could just jot things down on
paper and say yeah that would work
you know that's the kind of guys they
were yeah i mean
build something and then break it and
figure out how to make it so it wouldn't
break
yeah they did that a lot i mean it's
hard in some ways it's like it's hard
for me to understand because i'm always
you know i've always been interested in
science and i've you know
been very you know like we've said on
the show before i'm very spock-like in
the way that i'm very into like science
and logic and stuff
so it's hard for me to square
being really into science and having a
scientific mindset and then also
having belief in the occult or belief in
like fundamentalist religions or
something like that
that's very weird to me i don't like my
brain wouldn't doesn't work that way
i mean it's like but i yeah i can
understand like how other people might
have that but it's just like i can't
relate to directly because my brain
doesn't work like they were using all
their brain power to solve
certain specific tasks all right now i
do know
that a lot of the engineering that they
were doing it was backed up with
mathematics but a lot of it was
imagineering too
yeah the the the human mind its creative
functions are
very good almost like a super computer
somehow in a certain way
they could just draw something and go
that'll fly
you know what i mean by just drawing it
good that'll fly
or they'll just draw a [ __ ]
combustion chamber
and go okay ignition should happen right
here
well if you understand the principles
understand the principles
right you know in a really like
fundamental way
yeah but they were doing things inside
combustion chambers putting little veins
and things to make eddies to get more
complete combustion but they were doing
it just by instinct and imagination
yeah you could go back and check it with
a computer and go yeah that's real
[ __ ] close to what the computer was
saying yeah
so they were just doing it by imagining
it of what is happening in there
so the human mind's pretty [ __ ]
badass when you think about it it is as
long as you understand what it is you're
doing you can imagine how it should be
and it can come up yeah i mean when you
think about human brains yes they're
very clutch together yes they're very
messy
yes they have like a lot of blind spots
and
you know various things that go wrong
but
when you really step back and think
about it i mean the human brain is
really pretty amazing doing a lot of
stuff a computer can't do
and it's doing a bunch of stuff that
you're not aware of
in fact like probably 95 percent of the
[ __ ] that it's doing
is just [ __ ] that's going on like in the
just background noise which is like
mind-blowing to me
i mean because look i was reading a book
not too long ago
about all the [ __ ] that your brain does
that you're not like
conscious of and they're like do you
realize like how much
trouble it is for your brain to like
actually have you
walk they're like it's really really
difficult because and the reason
that they know it's difficult now is
because they've tried to build
robots like they can walk like a human
and it's really hard
yeah because it's like but your brain
does it and you're not even
aware of it yeah well it's all that
evolution right
yeah we've had millions of years of
trying to get our [ __ ] together trial
and error and everything i mean and like
i said
the human body is not perfect obviously
um you know people get backaches people
get you know
childbirth is painful and there's that's
evolution too
but evolution is not survival of the
fittest it's survival
of the fit enough yeah like it was good
enough
to not kill you so it's well you only
have to be good enough to reproduce once
exactly that's all exactly so it doesn't
have to be optimal
no it just has to be good enough the
whole idea
is can you live long enough and be
pretty enough
to your mate to reproduce at least once
yes that's all it takes that's all that
matters all that matters
that's all that matters being a pretty
motherfucker's part of it
all these creatures are pretty to some
to another creature
yeah even a blob fish even a blob fish
is somehow pretty to another mother it's
sexy to another
fish that's all right which that makes
me feel better about myself
i mean if you ever feel ugly just think
to yourself even blob fish are having
sex out there
if you've never seen a blob fish google
that [ __ ] yeah you'll feel a lot better
but yes i pick on the blob blobfish
they're cute
they're it you know in an ugly way but
so
so jack parsons he starts going he goes
to high school
and he did like fencing and [ __ ] like
that but he did kind of terrible in high
school because like i said he was
obsessed with rockets
and he didn't really give a [ __ ] about
any of the other you know
subjects so his mom pulls him out of
high school
and puts him in a military academy like
a private boarding school in san diego
he's not there very long before he blows
up
the toilets because you know
that's just what he did he blew [ __ ] up
that's an old trick though everybody was
trying to blow up the
toilet well he did it yeah he did it
they were doing that when i was in high
school dropping m80s in the toilets well
yeah that's just
now see i don't know if he'd just use
something as pedestrian as an m80 or if
he like
invented some special [ __ ] and you don't
throw the m80 in the toilet that's a
[ __ ]
that that's that because it'll just a
pro tip for anyone that wants to blow up
the toilets that they're putting
underneath the toilet seat
and light it i saw it done
you want maximum explosion yeah you put
a nice door
this is this show is just a wealth of
information
yeah and for going to prison i saw it
in case you're interested in like ever
wanting to have a life of crime
i saw it in the third grade you can tune
in and get some tips
i saw it in the third grade a fifth hour
a fifth grader put an m80 underneath the
[ __ ] toilet seat that was back before
they even had doors on the stalls back
in [ __ ] baths
in middle school and i was standing
there and [ __ ] looking at it and
boom and it shocked me blew that [ __ ]
seat up
huh yeah now did it blow the whole
toilet like that apart
no no blew the seat up [ __ ] smoke and
[ __ ] big old flash
it's kind of interesting yeah but they
were trying to crack it
yeah explode the toilet i mean i would
assume
i don't know i wasn't there but i would
assume
that jack parsons knew enough about
rocket accelerants and explosives to
make a really good one
yeah so i would think that he blew that
toilet up real good
i mean he did get expelled so
[Laughter]
so they moved to pasadena at this point
um the great depression starts to happen
because at this point we're
in 1930 thereabouts um and some of their
fortune starts to dwindle away
now they send jack to like a more
liberal
like private school and he does a lot
better there like because they weren't
um jack parsons seems like one of those
people that he's just very very
anti-authoritarian you know what i mean
that seemed like uh
you know something that was a hallmark
of his personality like through his
whole life
so when he was sent to a school where it
was
less about like you know just being told
what to do or wrote memorization or
something like that he did a lot better
when he was just kind of allowed to like
left to his own devices or when the
teaching methods were different
so uh he actually ended up editing the
school newspaper
and you know he won all kind of awards
like for literary things and whatnot
now he actually um wanted to study
chemistry now he started he wanted to go
to caltech
um but at this point like i said his
family's it was the depression so his
family's fortune was kind of like
being was ebbing away um so they
couldn't really afford to send him there
what he started doing was that when he
wasn't and he's still in school at this
point
he's like on weekends and evenings and
stuff he starts working
at this place called the hercules powder
company
and um so he starts like learning how to
mix explosives and
you know and learning more about rocket
propulsion and things like that because
that's what this company did
so he kind of got some on the job
training when he was still kind of a
teenager
now he also was still hanging out with
uh with
his friend edward foreman and they were
still like building rockets and doing
[ __ ] like that he would sometimes like
steal
some of the [ __ ] from his job so they
could come home and build like better
like rocket fuel and [ __ ] like that so
they could blow [ __ ] up
now even when when he was still a
teenager like i said he's still like
high school age at this point
he had built a solid fuel rocket engine
so he kind of like starts talking and at
this point
i guess like what this small scene or
whatever was kind of getting around so
at this point he starts corresponding
with some other like dudes like verner
von braun and like other people who were
kind of
in the vanguard of like the you know the
rocket
engineers at that point so he graduates
in 1933
they moved to a smaller house him and
his mom and his grandmother
now he enrolled at a junior college he
wanted to get a degree in uh
physics and chemistry but they didn't
really have enough money to pay his
tuition so he had to drop
out and he started working full-time at
the hercules powder company
now they sent him to hercules california
um
and so it was you know the their uh
you know company there and he started
making
his monthly wages at that place were 100
a month
which in 1933 was like a lot of money
that was like i think it was like 1200
1300
a month which was actually really good
for the time
um he actually started suffering from
headaches because he was constantly
exposed to nitroglycerin which i guess
that's one of the side effects of that
now he started like stocking money away
because he wanted to
go to stanford and get a degree in
chemistry
but the tuition was ultimately too much
for him even back then
so he couldn't afford it so he went back
to pasadena so he actually never he did
get some
formal education and on-the-job
education but he never did get
a full degree in any of the [ __ ] that he
was studying you know what i mean
yeah so he's kind of self-taught in a
way
yeah that wouldn't hold you back back
then knowing that no it didn't it it
didn't
because like i said you couldn't go to
school for half the [ __ ] they were doing
anyway
yeah as long as you could do the work
could talk the talk and get [ __ ] done
you could get
you could get a job contracted to any of
those [ __ ] government contractors
as long as you could deliver and that's
pretty much yeah that's
pretty much what happened to him it was
all experimental [ __ ] yeah like i said
they were like hot rodders
yeah they were you know i don't know if
you i don't know if that translates too
well people outside the united states
but a hot rod is just a guy i can make
[ __ ] for his car
yeah or his rifle you know they got guys
hot rod in the ar-15 now
you know uh a lot of guys can come up
with some crazy [ __ ] just by
imagineering
yeah if you're real interested in it
yeah a hobby is the most intense form of
study
a guy who's really into the [ __ ] he
doesn't really have to go to school for
he's gonna teach it himself
yeah i mean if you're interested enough
in something you're gonna see everything
you need to learn
yeah then you can just do it on your own
you don't need somebody like
telling you you can walk in and go i can
fix this i can do this and you can sit
there and just run it with another
trained engineer and he goes oh yeah he
knows he's talking about right you know
yeah so there was a lot of that yeah it
was not a [ __ ]
stuffed shirt corporate scene these were
wild men especially lockheed martin yeah
down there what you'd call area 51.
that was a [ __ ] it didn't exist in
this in the area you're talking about
here
yeah later on area 51 was nothing but
just
it wasn't it was called groom lake
that's what it was really called
yeah down there it was nothing but just
wild asses gangsters and [ __ ]
convicts because
all the [ __ ] staff who
cleaned the buildings and mowed the
yards and did all the [ __ ] normal
maintenance
they were all convicts and illiterate
guys
because the convict would the next car
wouldn't be believed yeah
so he could run his mouth and nobody
believe him right and they paid him in
cash
and then illiterate people couldn't read
anything so they couldn't spy
you know and then it was all these
[ __ ] crazy mad scientists making spy
planes
this is documented yeah but what was
funny is that
all these [ __ ] convict dudes can't
prove that they ever worked there
they were only paid in cash well that's
the way they wanted yeah that's why they
had it set up like that
they recognized one dude who was living
out in a trailer this is back in the
2000s early 2000s they gave him a
retirement check and admitted that yeah
he
he worked there for like 25 years
but they paid him in like a weird
securities circuitous route
to give him a retirement check that's
pretty interesting
they had a thing on tv about it but he
was there during the a bomb test and
everything
so all right so he wants so jack parsons
wanted to get
in with uh the dudes from like caltech
and stuff like that like i said he
didn't have all the credentials or
whatnot
so he gets introduced to a guy called
frank molina
who is a graduate student at caltech
and him and ed foreman his friend and
um jack they kind of get together and
they formed this sort of like little
i guess you call it like a little club
like a little loose club or something
like that
now the funny thing is it's called the
suicide squad
which is probably where the [ __ ] dc
got the name from
or whoever wrote the you know comic book
um they're called the suicide squad
obviously because they were always
blowing [ __ ] up and
could have been killed at any point in
time
so as i said when this was going on
i mean rocketry was still very much
seen as a science fiction yeah type of
thing like no one was really taking it
all
that seriously yeah and i got to
remember i want i don't want to for i
want to foreshadow this before you guys
lose track of this [ __ ]
this sounds like a science program but
we're talking about a [ __ ] that
eventually tries to bring about the
antichrist
tries to bring about the advent of the
antichrist we're gonna get that in a
minute
i don't even know if it was the
antichrist like the moon child i think
is what it was called
yeah which wasn't i mean he was trying
to bring about
like a scarlet woman or like the ideal
woman like a goddess
and then they were gonna have like a
spiritual
child not a real baby but a spiritual
baby
remember the invisible [ __ ] thought
monster yeah i kind of feel like that's
what they were doing
thank you thank you bunya let me see
some flash balls good morning guys just
woke up oh my goodness
what time is it in australia yeah oh my
god i don't even know this is the
beginning of the month
it is flash bulb day it is it's august
1st today
isn't it it is yeah it is it is the
beginning of the month i
totally forgot yeah so
so all these guys that formed the
suicide squad
they very quickly come to the
realization that jack parsons
um that his kind of contribution
to the world that he's the thing that he
was best at
was making rocket fuels and like i said
now
he was like a chemical genius he was
kind of like the dude that was
into that so um
because what you wanted was you wanted
something that was like
powerful enough to be able to you know
propel a rocket out of the atmosphere
but it had to be controllable so you
didn't just blow everything up
yeah you know what i'm saying which is a
very hard balance to
to achieve so
they eventually the germans eventually
figured it out but that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] dangerous and so bad
it was [ __ ] pure hydrogen peroxide
and i think the other one was like pure
chlorine
i think it was chlorine yeah so they
might correct me
you mix those two together they [ __ ]
immediate immediately explode it's
hypergolic
there's no reason to they don't even
need to ignite them with anything they
self-ignite that that [ __ ] there was bad
but it ate through all the damn gas
tanks and ate through all the gas lines
and it was difficult to handle
but as far as power to weight ratio
that's the one
that's the one to use they were using it
in the damn rocket planes
yeah yeah but parsons wouldn't have
known about that
[ __ ] was too [ __ ] volatile it was
hard to make
yeah yeah i don't think you'd have the
facilities you had to wear rubber suits
it was [ __ ]
extremely toxic yeah
sorry i was laughing at some of the uh
tammy just showed up and said did i miss
anything good
yeah you missed everything good just
blob fish and exploding toilets
yeah pretty much yeah
that was blob fishing exploding toilets
that's
what i should name it we're still in the
first hour uh we're just in an
hour he says in australia it's almost
eight in the morning it's like eight in
the morning
is that on the other side of the damn
planet isn't that weird yeah wait is it
eight
saturday morning or eight sunday morning
probably sunday are they behind or
in front of i can't remember i don't
know
i don't know i know well i know because
i used to live in the uk that there's a
five hour difference but i think it was
like five hours
later but i don't really know because
it's on like the opposite side of the
world so i'm just
really confused right now but yeah so
so the uh actual versions of
the fuel mixtures that jack parsons
ended up coming up with would like later
be used by
nasa so at the start of the 1940s
um molina he goes to the national
academy of sciences
and he asked them for funding
and he said he wanted to study what they
and they called it jet propulsion
because nobody wanted to call anything
rocket anything because it had that
stigma of like ooh
sci-fi you know what i mean yeah so they
had to call every anything everything
jet propulsion because it sounded like
more sciency well jet propulsion
also meant rockwood was any anything
other than propellers
it was but they just didn't want to call
in right
rocketry or rocket science or anything
they didn't want to call it anything
like that because the nate the word
rocket had like a
sci-fi stigma to it a rocket is a jet
and a jet is a rocket in a way yeah
it's just semantics yeah
i mean if you put a you take a jet
engine what we would call a jet engine
and then you just dump fuel in the
[ __ ]
in the exhaust stream in the back of it
it's called an afterburner
it thrusts just like a rocket that's
what an afterburner is it's like a
rocket
yeah the turbine blades are almost kind
of like a just a compressor
it's just a different interpretation of
jet jets and rockets are two different
interpretations of each other
you understand yeah yeah a lot of people
think there's a big difference but not
really
well no not really about the same for a
long time they weren't sure whether or
not fighter planes were going to be jet
or
rocket and in in a turbo
in a [ __ ] after burning jet has a lot
of
has a lot of attributes of a rocket but
only when the afterburner's on
yeah but you know
one thing or the other it's okay so
they're coming up with all this stuff
in the group um they also i mean they
had like they shared a lot of kind of uh
political views
um they smoked weed uh they were really
into drinking
they were kind of party dudes you know
yeah yeah they were all like that
so jack parsons and molina actually i
read
uh they wrote an uh science fiction
screenplay that was like
semi-autobiographical and they were
trying to like
pitch it to like hollywood execs even
though it was like a pacifist type of
movie
so that didn't go anywhere so jack
parsons ends up meeting
the woman that would be his first wife
in 1934
now he met her to church dance of all
places
so they get married in 1935.
now he ends up getting a job at a place
called halifax
powder company um and
even though like jack parsons was making
quite a bit of money at the time
but he would use pretty much all of his
money
to fund this new rocket research group
that they had started
so to make extra money he apparently was
uh making nitroglycerin in their house
um he had like a lab like in their porch
or their garage or something
and uh also at one point he pawned
helen's engagement ring which she was
not super happy about it
surprisingly he got it back though right
uh i don't yeah he got it i don't know
if he ever got it
he just put it in hawk to get some
[ __ ] cash
but yeah so um so they made some rockets
uh and they you know over this time
period and they were like launching them
but a lot of them
failed and like blew up or whatever um
you know
set fire uh you know because it was just
too combustible or whatever
now they uh they get another
uh a mathematician from caltech
uh and i'm sorry if i'm like because i'm
assuming this name it sounds it's
like a chinese name uh cheyenne shusen
and he actually joined the group in
1937.
so this is kind of so like i said this
is their little suicide squad group it's
very
it's not like official official like
there's there was no such thing as nasa
at this point
this is just like a bunch of guys who
were kind of funded by the national
academy of sciences
who were kind of working on
quote-unquote jet propulsion
and we're kind of getting funding where
they could get it you know what i mean
um another thing that happened around
this time period
um that kind of pushed jack parsons into
the spotlight a little bit
and made him like legitimize him i guess
is like an expert in you know rocket
fuel and in
various like explosive devices was he
actually acted as a witness in a trial
of this guy named captain earl kynette
he was like the head of police
intelligence in la
and he was accused of a conspiracy of
setting a car bomb
in uh an attempted murder case
like with this private investigator
named harry raymond who was former lapd
his car had blown up i don't know if he
was killed in it or not i guess not
because it was attempted murder
but um so this guy who was like the head
of the police was accused
and jack parsons actually gave testimony
at that trial like about the
explosive and how the car bomb was
probably made
and his testimony they think like helped
to convict that guy
so after that happened it was kind of a
very public trial so after that happened
like jack parsons got
um kind of a reputation as being like
the go-to guy like expert
on explosives and stuff so he was like
the guy they would go to
whenever they needed somebody to talk
about explosives
yeah well internal combustion and
external combustion are all the same
thing he'd be the man to know if he's
making rocket fuel it's a type of
explosion
yeah you would think that right so at
this point
um you know there's other kind of [ __ ]
going on he's doing the rocket stuff
he's also like a little bit in some
political groups i think he kind of
flirted with marxism
communism stuff like that even though he
was never really
completely down with communism um
but he did go to some of the meetings
and stuff which would get him in trouble
later on
uh people don't realize how far back
that goes in america he was in the aclu
he was in like other things like that
yeah um but he didn't want to join the
american communist party which was very
small at the time
um even though he was interested in what
some of the meetings but he wasn't
all the way down with that so he um
ends up getting into the occult
probably through like some friends of
theirs
so in 1939 there's this other couple
that him and his wife
helen know they're called john and
francis baxter
and they take jack and helen to the
felima
church or the church of salima in uh
hollywood
yeah so you guys know who that is yeah
that's
uh what's his name alistair yeah
so they go to this uh thing and he saw
um they did like a gnostic mass
and there were other like kind of famous
people there at the time like john
carradine
was into it and like there was um harry
haye who was like a gay rights activist
at the time in 1939 um
so jack parsons got very very interested
in this belief system in this occult
belief system of felima
so he had already kind of knew a little
bit about felima about the oto
the ordo template orientas which we
talked about when we talked about the uh
the aleister crowley
show and he had read some crowley um
in the past so he kind of got into it
so he um he kind of like got
he met like a lot of the members of the
church and
got friendly with them and starts going
back to their
events and starts reading more books by
aleister crowley
and he starts trying to get his wife
into it like trying to get her to read
them
and he started to think that maybe there
was something to this whole
felima magic thing mainly
he kind of thought of it the same way
that we kind of talk about
poltergeist activity in the sense that
he thought that quantum physics
would eventually explain that what he's
basically getting at
is that it's kind of like what in modern
day
you would think of as you know remember
that book that came out the secret
that's kind of like the law of
attraction like if you put something out
in the universe like the universe will
provide for you
it's kind of something like that if you
put the energy or the intent that you
put out in the universe
if you put it out in the right way it
should come back to you if you do it
in the right way um a lot of the [ __ ]
they were doing was
sex magic obviously because there was a
there was kind of an understanding that
because sex or having orgasms was such a
powerful
human thing that while you were in the
midst of that that it would make your
intent or your you know the magic or the
you know the intent that you were
sending out into the universe it would
make it that much more
powerful yeah you know what i'm saying
plus it was a good way of getting laid
well
exactly and it's you know that was i
think that was a happy
yeah i think that's kind of what it was
about too i mean and i'm not saying it's
like you know people have believed all
kinds of things
um so i'm not saying that he didn't
actually because he really did seem to
actually believe
in these things maybe more than some of
the other people that were there
well but i kind of understand it you
know with my with my own personal
experience of poultry guys
activity how
based on what i saw emotion can somehow
alter
your consciousness and to a point to
where you start doing where weird things
start happening in the environment
rspk yeah okay
so maybe they're saying the emotions
from sex can do it
that's kind of what they were getting at
yet but in my experience no i think it's
the dark more the darker emotions
fear anger fear anger frustration
yeah that does it yeah you know in my
opinion but like you said
you know this this belief system at
least has
the you know happy side effect of
getting laid and free love and all that
and you might if you got a good cult
you're going to attract hotties
you might get you might get mayla nermie
yeah that's vampire if you guys
earliest goth yeah with chelsea haircut
and everything
she did super hot i could not believe
that when i saw that [ __ ] picture
for some reason um holy crap yeah james
dean didn't like her evidently he dated
her and it's like i gotta get rid of her
she's been [ __ ] crazy
either that or maybe james dean was just
a dick
i mean that could be true yeah well both
of those things could be true
yeah well i think they were both pretty
difficult to be around if you ask me
yeah and when you get two people that
are difficult to be around maybe they
can't be around each other because
they're just both too difficult
he could drive a car though evidently he
couldn't
dodge that damn truck but actually
people people said that he really didn't
have much choice i mean the headlights
of the arrow wasn't weren't very good
and he did try to swerve instead of
break
[ __ ] man they didn't even have the
headlights weren't that good they didn't
even have seat belts until
i think this car had i think that
porsche spider might have had racing
seat belts in it don't think
oracle says funny how beautiful women
are always essential to sex magic but
the men don't have to be handsome
well exactly and that's true of porn
that's kind of true of anything
they just have to have the money to
afford the situation yeah
back in the day you can look like ron
jeremy he's still being porn but ron
jeremy was good looking when he was
young he was a play girl centerfold
he used to be in shape i don't know it's
i just feel like back then well you he's
known for the hit for
for the hedgehog period the hedgehog
fairy
yeah [ __ ] tubby and harry and [ __ ]
but in the 70s i saw i'm not judging i'm
sure some people are into that look
he was you know in the 70s he was what
was popular in the 70s he had the
handlebar mustache and the
you know like this and he he kind of was
like a uh
oh [ __ ] what was that like a burt
reynolds
yeah type guy which i was never into
that either that was a popular look
i know it was i don't know i just i
didn't get it even in the 70s i didn't
get i mean i was a kid in the 70s but i
didn't get it
i don't know i don't i don't like facial
hair well so i guess because my dad had
a beard and mustache so it's just like
that'd be like lusting after your dad
and that's weird
you know what i'm saying yeah you're
looking at it from from your point of
view
well you know [ __ ] guys guys aren't
looking at it from that point of view
i'm just saying
that that what what was popular at that
particular time was kind of a dude with
a mustache and he had a
cowboy hat like the marlboro man yeah i
remember but he was like a cool dude and
he had a [ __ ] trans am he had a
transition
and he [ __ ] walked around and and
said funny [ __ ] but would you know what
i mean
and try to act like a badass but what
was funny is that
for the era i guess people didn't really
recognize didn't notice it at the time
those dudes had no physical fitness
well nobody did it wasn't really a thing
yeah i mean like really fit dudes like
weightlifting and stuff like because we
did the show about that it was like not
cool back then
well it was like a very very small like
a subculture and it was a gay thing
really
i think it was more of a gay thing yeah
i mean not entirely but that was like a
large part of it
in the 70s the action heroes
of the 70s very few of them worked out
all right
thank you bunya thank you very much let
me see cement down flash bulbs
and then when they did work out they hid
the fact that they worked out because
that was cheating
you were just supposed to be a badass
and big and strong by your own and you
were just supposed to lay around
and lay around and be about it big
[ __ ] american hamburgers and get
strong as [ __ ] just sitting there belt
back some [ __ ] budweiser and that
explains that
still be in shape that explains charlton
heston because
he the hest would walk around like he
was a [ __ ] 20 feet tall and just as
badass and he'd take his shirt off like
he was a badass but you're looking at
him you go dude put your shirt back on
put the [ __ ] shirt back on well in a
lot of ways it was like
much easier back then like especially
for dudes because it's like you could
basically look like anything like
nowadays
both women and men you have to [ __ ]
if you're gonna be in the movies
you got to have personal trainers you
got to have nutritionists and chefs
you got to have all yeah and you got to
like do all this stuff because you have
to look for and even then
it's not good enough because they still
got a cgi your ass they'll cgi some abs
on there and [ __ ]
it's like so you're still you do all
that you're still not good enough
and i hate to hate to [ __ ] you know
shatter your image of these [ __ ]
celebrities
and these [ __ ] marvel these guys in
these marvel movies that's anabolic
steroids
well yes i don't think anyone's like
upset about that
antibodies a lot of people don't believe
that and like i said
some of it's cgi too yeah like after
like it's posed
daniel craig i'm now convinced that was
not anabolic steroids
well he's not a huge dude he's just in
good shape he's just in good shape and
he was always in pretty much good shape
yeah and for james bond he put on a
couple of pounds of muscle but that'd be
easy to do without anabolics
he just and for the character i mean
he's not like
[ __ ] arnold and predator he's james
bond he's supposed to mostly be
like shooting and we're side tracking
and i know these [ __ ] love it
when we sidetrack
i just got done watching predator again
arnold is not as stupid big as people
think he is in that movie
he was a lot smaller than he was in his
well yeah
but you can see like in the conan era in
his body in his weightlifting era
he's lost a lot of weight yeah he had
good size
guns and a nice chest and [ __ ]
but he's nowhere near as big as he was
in conan
yeah he's just none of those guys
actually are
people people are imagining them being
bigger than what they really are
you were if you were to put those guys
up against bodybuilders of today
those guys look small yeah but like
bodybuilders
today are [ __ ] freaky they're
monsters freakishly
although i do feel like and we talked
about this a little bit on the
weightlifting show
was that i feel like there was there was
a peak where it's like it was just peak
monster where it's just like you had to
just get it big as possible even if it
looked
terrible but i feel like it's going a
little bit more toward like
not so freakish looking nowadays like a
little more natural
a lot of people don't realize that back
in the 70s
if you talk about just physique one of
the guys with the best physiques you
never would notice it
until you see him walking about his
shirt off with charles bronson
yeah charles bronson [ __ ] worked out
he worked out he he looked really good
he had a high wife too and um but you
don't they don't really showcase him in
his movies
yeah you know he was a different type of
character he played different types he
was a short
guy but he was uh he worked out he
looked he looked really good
yeah yeah i mean you know if he were to
make him bigger
and put him side by side with arnold and
predator not that different
not like that yeah but you just can't
really tell
in the movies that he was in but like i
said that wasn't really like a lot of
the characters he was playing
so all right so like i said jack parsons
been going
to this the lima church getting into
all this type of getting interested in
all this sex magic type of stuff
now around this time
um he starts
uh kind of lusting after
his wife's younger sister
sarah otherwise known as betty now
at the time they met i believe she was
only
17 years old
so that's a little weird i mean you know
what i mean it's like she's not super
young but still
and also that's your wife's sister so
again a little weird
now i feel like jack parsons wife
she kind of went along with the thalima
thing for a little while like they get
initiated into this one lodge
uh in the early 1940s like 1941.
um you know they're all up with aleister
crowley they meet him they're
you know they're very like high up in
the [ __ ]
so but as time went on
as they got more into i mean it got to a
point too where they were talking about
jack parsons being like
aleister crowley's like successor like
at this particular
lodge or this particular so you know
what i mean he was kind of like high up
in the rankings
but it did get to a point where his wife
was just kind of like when they get into
the sex magic and all the orgies and
everything like that she's like
yeah i just don't know if this is really
what i'm
what i want to do you know what i mean
so at this point
it seems like he kind of
went back and went after
his wife's younger sister i'm gonna make
another drink
yeah like i said she was like oops well
that was my
that was my little thing right there so
yeah so
there was that whole kind of thing going
on now
another thing that happened too and this
kind of started to occur
in the 1930s maybe even earlier
was that because of jack's
interest in the occult and his
relationship with
aleister crowley and his involvement
with all of these
quote-unquote satanic groups or that's
at least how they were perceived
also he had very leftist political
beliefs he had flirted like i said with
marxism he wasn't a communist but he had
gone to like some of the communist
meetings he was interested in that type
of thing
and so he kind of got onto the fbi's
radar and they kind of started
watching him i don't know how early they
started watching him
um and he kind of like said later on
that he thought they were watching him
for like a really long time before then
and i don't really have any reason to
doubt that because it did come out later
that they had been watching them
so i'm not sure when they started it was
probably some time in the 40s
but um i it kind of ramped up later on
because
they accused him of uh
spying which i don't think he really was
they did like a couple of independent
like investigations of it and it didn't
seem like he was doing anything he just
did like one thing and it wasn't yeah it
was just like him being dumb or like not
thinking about the optics of it i don't
think he was like
spying for anyone but the fbi kind of
perceived it that way so he was kind of
under surveillance
for a time so
uh like i said they get into oh thank
you very much
oh my goodness
oh that's so nice of you thank you very
much thank you very much bunya but it's
like it's really nice
that you guys come by and hang out with
us on saturday nights and whenever else
we record
i'm just like going i don't even know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
i've only had one drink but yeah
so like i said i was talking earlier
about
uh crowley and about their whole
you know do it thou wilt type of thing
so they were very
individualistic not so much satanic but
they really did
kind of feel like what you know
that people couldn't really like tell
you what to do and i should say that
jack parsons
was actually again very ahead of his
time
in the sense that he was very
egalitarian he was very
uh for women's rights for women's
equality
he was very into the government not
policing sexual morality um
so he did hang out with a lot of uh you
know kind of progressives liberals stuff
like
at that time who were kind of trying to
you know get the government out of like
people's sex lives or
you know keep like the morality police
type of thing so
he was like up in that he really did
seem to believe in those
uh ideals of having men and women be
equal having you know having
you know not not being laws against
homosexuality or against like
adultery or against things like that so
he was very much ahead of his time in
that
uh way and hung out with the that scene
of people
um you know and even later on in the 50s
like with the beats and everything like
that his writings
were very popular with them so
so he basically he's made like quite a
bit of money
from working on uh you know
all these rockets and fuels and uh you
know working for these companies he's
been working for
and he actually ended up um earning
enough money
to buy a mansion in pasadena
which he ended up calling the parsonage
because his last name was parsons so
yeah so he calls it the parsonage
because of course he did and uh so this
um mansion ends up becoming
kind of like the party house man
that's like everybody was going there
for the orgies and the drugs you've seen
these
i mean big old flash bulbs you missed
all the orgies in the truck yes
upset it's 20 oh my god that's awesome i
know
thank you very much thank you
yeah so they're having all these uh he's
there with
his uh 17 year old sister-in-law
engaging in some quote-unquote sex magic
uh you know everyone's got drugs
um everyone's having orgies
everyone's just having a good old time
thank you very much matt
i just you saw it before i did i have a
lag on mine
um some people have some people that
actually went to some of these parties
that he had at the parsonage
described it as looking like a fellini
movie which like i said
sounds like a good time this sounds like
like some cool [ __ ] people
in the 1940s man they're doing like
they're
having [ __ ] drug orgies in the 1940s
that goes way back though that's what i
mean it's like i i kind of feel like
people thought that [ __ ] didn't happen
until the 1960s
that she goes back to the roman era well
yeah and even
even in the young united states i mean
the 1920s were pretty [ __ ] crazy too
like all the [ __ ] drinking and [ __ ]
there was also stuff going on in the
1700s there were many sexual revolutions
lots of them in the 1770s here in the
united states during the time of the
american revolution that was also a time
of a sexual revolution
going on yeah benjamin franklin was into
all that nudism and free love and
oh yeah i got married you know there's
all kinds of stuff had a bunch of
girlfriends
well i think i mean free love has been
advocated
since i mean [ __ ] there's like at least
like the late 19th century had h.g wells
like people like that
mary wollstonecraft like people like
that who's mary shelley's mom
um you know people like that like
advocating
not so much for just like [ __ ]
everybody indiscriminately but
for being able to have relationships
inside and outside of marriage without
it being
um like made illegal you know what i
mean
so like i said jack parsons was actually
he was a big
advocate of sexual freedom of
women's rights and things like that so
he was like very much at the vanguard
i got to show my boy on there look check
that out that's [ __ ] charles bronson
man
he was your [ __ ] went okay he was jacked
hold on
you can't really see his arms in there
hold up i mean the lag is getting me
there you go he was [ __ ] jacked man
he's gonna find a better
look at this pipe oh there you go there
you go bigger
[Laughter]
there you go i'm just laughing at the
pipe that's what i'm left yeah you can't
see
his arm in that picture but not through
the camera but he was [ __ ] a lot
bigger than people think he was
well yeah like i said because they
always put like in the death wish movies
which is probably what he's best known
for they kind of just put him in like
long sleeve suits
right here's a good picture of him
michael shafer says stabbing my eyes out
thinking of ben franklin nude
right that might have been that might
have been like some [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] jacked man
he just got his crush this crotch i
can't [ __ ] do the [ __ ] the lag's
getting me i know
i tried to like [ __ ] for the 70s man
that was the [ __ ]
dude he's actually yeah he is actually
much bigger than i
did not look like that in the 70s not
like i've seen him in a lot but
you know
yeah so all right so like i said
in the 1940s because jack was
um you know rocket scientist by day
sex magic occultist by night fbi
kind of not having it so um they kind of
put him under surveillance
so uh he uh gets
laid off from uh aerojet where he had
been working
uh at that time and he gets like paid
off
for the shares that he had invested in
the company and they're basically like
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here because
you're
making us look bad with all your sex
magic shenanigans
so at this point jack doesn't really um
is not really having a job i think what
ended up happening
to him unfortunately um which happened
to kind of a lot of
similar types of people around this time
period especially during the mccarthy
area the
era the red scare and all that was that
he basically got blacklisted from
working
in rocketry at all so
he ended up later like
working at gas stations and being like a
car mechanic and [ __ ] like that because
he wasn't allowed he was like black bald
um because of his association with
crowley because of his
um you know former flirtation with
marxism because of this that and the
other
so they didn't really want him they
thought they didn't trust him they
thought that maybe he was a spy and [ __ ]
like that even though
there's no evidence that he did anything
like that
so saying something no sandra i don't he
didn't he wasn't native american charles
bronson i think was polish wasn't he
i think if i remember correctly i think
he i don't know if he was born in poland
for his
parents i think his parents were
careless i think his parents might have
been poland or poland or czechoslovakia
or something like that he was
eastern europe he's european i could be
totally wrong about it i haven't been
russian but i remember him being eastern
european or
poland i don't know is that eastern
europe megas maybe it is
yeah yeah my stepmom's from poland yeah
so i think he was
that's just off top of my head though
that sounds correct though i remember i
think i remember reading that somewhere
unless we
was going to that lutheran lithuanian
yeah it was something yeah some with
them
it might have been lithuanian or
something i'm sure people in latvia are
going we're not poland [ __ ]
sorry you always kind of picture i
always kind of picture bronson being
this [ __ ] craggly face
kind of smaller guy that really not real
physical no that [ __ ] was jacked
yeah he was jacked man but they never
showcased that in any of his movies
walking around that dude was [ __ ] big
man big ol arms on him he was hiding his
light under a bushel
it looks it looks i don't want to say it
looks like anabolics but
maybe i don't know it's hard to say it's
hard to say
yeah i mean
he was young in that picture maybe not
it might have been lifted
lithuanian somebody says yeah i think
about it lithuanian right
that's yeah that sounds right i knew bad
ass though yeah dude
he's not tall like he was five five five
six yeah he's stacked
same height well that's you're five six
right yeah five six yeah about the same
size as me
i'm five foot three he's in better shape
than me though i'm [ __ ] in that
picture he's lean
i got 10 pounds to lose easy if i were
to lose 10 pounds i'd probably look like
that maybe
his legs don't match somebody said whose
legs don't matter
so he said it's anabolics his legs don't
match uh
no internet says he was five foot nine
no not true not true i don't know i kind
of feel like they always
trying to like exaggerate i always now
see now i want to go to tom cruise's
wikipedia page
and see what his thing says tom cruise
is about five
five five six and and the thing well
i see now this always kind of bothered
me it always bothered me
that dudes were so insecure about their
height
it really i mean it's like a [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] it doesn't
matter you know what i mean i mean i
maybe maybe to some chicks it matters it
i it honestly never even occurred to me
you can look to care about it it
honestly never did
i've always heard that charles bronson
was about five five five six five seven
around that around that air around
around that size
yeah yeah he doesn't look very big
he says he was born in the u.s i thought
he might have been born in the us but i
thought his parents were
somewhere else what immigrants yeah
right that's what i thought we're just
talking about his ethnic background
yeah yeah i was thinking it was polish
but it might have been lithuanian sounds
about right he was something kind of
eastern european e
kind of now uh what oh what's his name
eul brenner was part
mongolian yeah a lot of people don't
know that i think i think
his parents were from mongolia i think
mark says height doesn't matter only
money and dong
exactly and how much you can talk yeah
other things matter too
um you dress [ __ ] badass and money's
nice
dong is nice but charisma yeah
i i think actually if you don't have
either money or dong
um you need some like [ __ ]
personality
and that will take you a long way like i
said depends on the chick
but i don't really i've never really had
i just like the people that i like i
don't really care about how much money
they have or how big their dick is or
anything like that
it's it's just never been a
consideration yeah
okay no i'm just saying in my in my in
my
observation of dudes that [ __ ] do
well it's always charisma
exactly well that's what i'm saying
always charisma but the thing is be
funny or be sweet or be something
there's a bunch of [ __ ] but the thing is
is that a guy who has charisma
not only does it work on women it
usually works on men too it works on
everybody so what ends up happening is
they tend to be successful also
because you're a likable because
everybody's everybody's helping you they
like you they want you to hire you
to be likeable that's the long and short
of it just be a likable person they want
to work with you they want you to be
represent them with this and that blah
blah blah blah charisma is more
important than anything
anything yeah everything's charisma yeah
like i said have a good personality be a
cool person
just be cool you know be interesting
listen to people when they talk to you
do [ __ ] like that it's like it's easy
it's easy every man that was successful
did it on the back of charisma
unless he inherited the money and then
that's not his success that was his
ancestors success
right just look at arnold arnold had
[ __ ] charisma everybody liked him
even though he was stuck up and he
looked a certain way he ended up being
the governor of california
they laughed at him when they said he
when he said he was going to be a famous
actor
no he was that accent [ __ ] yeah
he conquered [ __ ] hollywood
another thing it's all charisma another
thing you have to do too and this is
probably like an aspect of charisma is
that you have to take what other people
maybe would perceive as a weakness like
arnold did like
he has a really thick accent yeah and
turn it into a strength that became
arnold
right make that like part of you that's
your thing
and if you listen to people who knew
arnold what you see in the movies that's
not the way arnold what
arnold was arnold was not serious he was
not
this in the movies he's kind of an
archetype he's almost kind of a
cartoon that's not the way he really was
in in real life
in real life he was a [ __ ] prankster
and he was [ __ ] joking around and
would [ __ ] talk a lot of [ __ ] and he
he had a lot of charisma people liked
him even though
in the bodybuilding scene a lot of
people a lot of guys [ __ ] said he was
stuck up and [ __ ] talk a lot of [ __ ]
because he was
in a competition constantly yeah you
know and
but if he wasn't competing if you
weren't if you weren't competing against
him he'd be joking around with you
yeah that's kind of guy was he i kind of
feel like
i don't really like i don't like
arrogance
unless you're self-aware of your
arrogance and you're just doing it
ironically
but if you're just arrogant and you
actually do think that you're better
than everybody then no i just want to
punch you in there now jimmy
said that in in the movies arnold is not
a very sexy guy and
he he's not really he's not no i don't
find him he's not
he's funny and he's like interesting and
he's like a good character and stuff but
sexually attractive not really but you
know what's funny is that i saw some
behind the scenes clips of him
hanging out with the girl from predator
one
yeah and she's [ __ ] grabbing up on
him because she's a famous actress
someday
yeah and well she's been in tons of yeah
and he's he's
not nothing like he is in the movies you
can see that in in reality he is
very attractive women like him and he
doesn't
the way he acts off screen is a lot more
accessible
i don't know maybe i'd have to meet him
now yeah this in person he's he he's
very natural
because like i said it's it's hard to
it's not the way it's not what you see
in on right and for me like i said
particularly
being a woman and maybe this is a
generalization but it's like unless i
know that person
like in person i don't know if they're
sexually attractive or not because like
i don't know you
so it's like if i just see you up on the
screen yeah you can look sexy and
everything like that but if i meet you
and you're a dick
then suddenly you're not sexy anymore he
was acting real natural she was [ __ ]
definitely into him
definitely and he was okay well like
that's fair enough
i mean like i said i've never met him in
real life so i don't know no he was just
[ __ ] being cool with [ __ ] jokes
he might be totally sexy if you meet him
in real life i'm just saying in the
movies
he doesn't stretch like i'm not saying
that it's not oh what happened
oh i thought you dropped your drink i
was like oh no
so much time so much liquor wasted but
yeah i i
you know in the movies i'm just saying i
never found him like personally it's not
my type really i mean
i don't i don't know i don't have a type
but in real life he even was very
popular with the women very
yeah yeah well you know like i said i
buy it
i'm kind of a weirdo yeah i mean you
know yeah yeah
he tells me this all the time
everybody's saying uh i'm gonna
yeah i knew he wasn't you know i thought
he was from here but i knew his parents
were probably not from here
so okay so like i said jack parsons um
he gets in trouble with the fbi they
start stalking him for his
whatever the hell he's doing and he
loses his job
so he starts uh getting like even more
into the occult and getting more into
that [ __ ]
and then he meets the famous
l ron hubbard now elrond hubbard at this
point
had not started scientology yet okay
this is still the 1940s and we've had
all kinds of shows on scientology you've
had the anger gay pope on here and he's
been on here like three times
i'm actually an admirer of l ron hubbard
for what he was able to achieve just by
telling a good story
i don't like scientology i don't like
the church of scientology i don't like
david miscavige and what they do
but the best thing about scientology was
l ron hubbard
everybody he everybody liked him and he
was
well except for jack parsons because he
stole a bunch of his money but pretty
much everybody
everybody all the cultists in
scientology liked him and he didn't
really
abuse women or anything you know and he
had the opportunity to
he was a very unique cult leader
um he was surrounded by young
scientology girls and
he wasn't getting it on with him or
abusing him
not that anyone ever has said everyone
says no
and i kind of believe that because
that's how weird he was
yeah because a real cult leader would
have been dogging them all out
and i was like that's not good either
but not doing that
is almost weird it's almost weirder
right because that's the [ __ ]
stereotype he actually believed his own
[ __ ]
i believe that he believes which to me
is crazy yeah that's crazy
and he was just kind of a that dude was
a [ __ ] lunatic he was a mediocre
naval
naval commander of a [ __ ] what was a
destroyer
in world war ii that didn't see much
action they don't think you saw any
action
i mean a war hero though to his credit
um he did write a voluminous amount of
sci-fi
uh which was very fairly well regarded
and it sold a lot
um i you know i have maybe a biased
opinion because like i said i have
firsthand experience with a
scientologist because i lived in
clearwater and i worked for
a company that was owned by them and um
so i had to read l ron hubbard's uh
dribblings pretty much every working day
of my life and i felt like it was making
me leak
iq points yeah bailey so uh
and making me crazy at the same time
every time i've met a scientologist
[ __ ] and i ran across a couple one
time at starbucks and i just i was like
i was thrust into a [ __ ] parallel
universe
i didn't know what i was dealing with
the insanity do you
realize that they were scientologists
yeah it's [ __ ] man
i told you i told you can you imagine i
could only stay at that company for
eight months can you imagine
five days a week eight nine hours a day
yeah interacting with people like that
yeah
for all that time i mean you know
everything and they don't [ __ ] know
what they're talking about
and those kind of people irritate me
more than any and a lot of people
irritate me okay let's be honest
but nobody irritates me more than stupid
people
that think they're smart oh my god that
makes me so angry yeah
[Laughter]
larping that they have special and
that's exactly what scientology
and i think that's exactly why after
eight months i was like i gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here or i'm going to
jump off a building i mean i really
couldn't take it
yeah i yeah i kind of i kind of
think scientology kind of
that could have been something but
they tried to make an alternative to
psychology and psychiatry
and they tried to make something that
was better than psychiatry or psychology
but it didn't work
i mean i don't really asleep
psychology is not really a science i
think that's also kind of a philosophy
more thing else it's hard difficult to
prove what people think
um psychiatry is a science
it doesn't just because it's a science
doesn't mean it's good i think there's a
lot of abuses in psychology psychology
and psychiatry i kind of stay away from
that [ __ ] i think it's a lot of witch
doctory in a lot of it
um taking mind altering drugs to solve
problems unless you're [ __ ] crazy i
think it's a battle
some people need it some people are
[ __ ] crazy some people need it they
used to give them [ __ ]
lobotomies and instead of that they just
give them like a chemical lobotomy i
understand
that because some people just you just
can't let them walk around they're
[ __ ] crazy
but giving them everybody all these
weird [ __ ] psychotropic drugs and
[ __ ]
weird neural inhibitors instead of just
dealing with the problem of that look
you're depressed because your life sucks
let's fix your life
you know what i mean that's that's
really the they're just making money off
selling drugs to people really yeah
because the thing about it is that
people who actually suffer from
depression
it's not anything to do with their
situation they could be in a good
situation
but they're still but they're still
depre because it's a brain chemical
thing
so it's like i understand like yeah it's
in some circumstances you know you might
need something like that but i think in
general i think there's a lot
of abuse of it yeah but i'm just i'm not
going down the scientology road of like
nobody needs drugs everybody just needs
to like [ __ ]
fast in a hotel room until no hang on
work until you die of starvation and get
eaten by cockroaches
like like oh what's your name yeah
it's like that they hand that [ __ ] out
like candy to too many people yeah i
just think they
over profit in it right but i don't
think that means that it doesn't have
any value because obviously it does do a
lot of people thank you very much bro
so oh thank you nico thank you
what can we expect from a world ruled by
psychos
uh whom ourselves vote in i don't know
yeah i think i would say voting matters
when i was saying that um
that the people i hated most were stupid
people that thought they were smart alex
ramirez said i think that's most people
i was like yeah
i'm starting to think so as well
but it's just like i don't well because
i think the thing about it and but
we should do a whole [ __ ] show about
the dun and krueger effect because
i feel like people that don't that just
know a little bit about something
yeah are like really dangerous because
they just know a little bit about
something
so they think they know everything
whereas people who are actually smart
and actually know about things know that
there's a [ __ ] ton of stuff they don't
know so they tend to be a lot more
humble
um and not like jump into like oh i know
everything about everything
so it's so i feel like dunning krueger
is just
everywhere and i just feel like and it's
just that makes me madder than anything
else and scientologists
they have this weird thing like the ones
that i worked with
even the ones that were because like i
said they're kind of into
child labor let's say that so some of
the people that
right so some of the people that were
working in this company like in
managerial positions
we're like 16. yeah so you have some
16 year old idiot telling you what
and they're looking at you all
fresh-faced and wide-eyed
and like telling you this [ __ ] and
i'm just looking at them going
what the [ __ ] do you like you know
nothing about
anything like why are you you question
them they think there's something wrong
with you
exactly and that just oh it's crazy
making
it's crazy making what's weird about
scientology is scientology is a very
1950s
cold war feeling
big time very very corporate
yeah take the corporate because it has a
military
background l ron hubbard was a military
officer
this came from an era where the military
and the corporations were merging
and the military really liked the way
corporations did things so it started to
take on like a corporate faith
face so it kind of made sense to make a
religion that was corporate
and kind of merged in with some kind of
like
psychology but also something kind of
like
uh magic in a way yeah and
it kind of had the same
kind of kind of had the same game that
[ __ ] old
uh [ __ ] alistair crawley had with the
oto
where you paid them and they'd make you
a [ __ ] wizard basically is what it is
well and
i mean elrond hubbard got most of the
ideas from crowley
crowley right sure so you join
scientology and you pay them
and they train you to become a super
scientologist and so you could
eventually become a wizard yeah you're
essentially a wizard a 1950s arrow
cold war space wizard kind of like a
jedi
that's what they're doing you're you're
paying to become a jedi which i get that
like look everybody wants to better
themselves
everybody wants to think that you know
if i just like work hard at this
specific thing like my life will be
happy like i'll be successful i'll be
rich i'll be this that the other
but sometimes [ __ ] doesn't work out the
way you want
and you can't like force it you can't do
that as you're moving up the bridge you
go through these different courses
all right and uh what are they called oh
do you go through these ot levels
right and as you go operating fee
operating state
operating satan levels and each each
level you got to pay a certain amount of
money to pass through to the next level
it's making a [ __ ] a wizard
that's the same thing [ __ ]
crowley would do well
it's okay until you probably get to like
ot4 and then you realize what
i think is ot4 or ot5 what is it i can't
remember what i thought it was ot8 but i
guess
i could be wrong now talk about the ones
when you find out it's basically about
alien souls
i thought that was ot i thought but i
could be wrong about that i could be
remembered
so you pay tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
then they tell you guess what
guess what there's demons there's demons
in a volcano
and then and there's xenu and what you
find out is you find out that
it's it's a religion that is based
around
demonic possession all right that you've
been demonically possessed by alien
souls
that have been exercised out of you
and they exercise these alien souls out
of you
by basically going through confession
on a lie detector and now you know it's
hands it's a light it's a very primitive
lie detector machine
and you're giving up all your [ __ ]
secrets and confessing all these sins
and they're recording them
that way if you leave they got dirt on
you and they can [ __ ] release that to
the public
oh well he's a homosexual which like
that's a bad thing in [ __ ]
scientology they matter of fact try to
curate
gayness they do that's why john travolta
is in there it's like pray the gay
awakening
yeah praying the gay away you know and
not down with that man
yeah so that's why they can't leave i
think there's only one person that
actually got in modern which is dumb
because it's like dude it's 20 20.
it's not scientology though yeah no [ __ ]
not in scientology in scientology it's
1956.
yeah no [ __ ] yeah that's the problem
with it right there that was a long time
ago yeah
some people want to talk about tom
cruise i do not believe
i do not believe that well first of all
i believe that tom cruise
got top scientology training i think he
his experience in scientology was
probably the best experience you could
get
that's what i mean he didn't get [ __ ] on
like all the [ __ ] peons
it treated that [ __ ] like a kid
they built whole [ __ ]
special bases for tom cruise to go [ __ ]
he goes to like a certain place and
they're like well he likes this
particular type of flower so we're
just going to make a whole field this
flower so him and nicole kidman because
this is when they were married
they could frolic in this field of
flowers they planted the whole [ __ ]
field
yeah so he could do that now scientology
isn't a [ __ ] two-bit
operation they got military like
military-style bases
all over well they're mentioned real
estate really
magnates yeah pretty much they got a
[ __ ]
secret base out in the middle of the
desert
armed with it looks like a maximum
security prison
huge [ __ ] walls and
[ __ ] concertina wire
and there's underground vaults filled l
ron hubbard's writings on [ __ ] what
is it [ __ ]
lead tablets or platinum plant no it's
not platinum
i don't remember what it is it's some
kind of [ __ ] metal
with titanium titanium titanium tablets
i was thinking of platinum
right and they're all stored and all
these [ __ ]
it can it could the thing can survive a
nuclear [ __ ] blast
you know i mean to uh and it's all a
[ __ ] al ron hubbard's [ __ ]
dianetics
i'm telling you right now scientology is
exhibit one
in why people that have money like don't
deserve that [ __ ]
and you know what i mean and that's just
because there's a weird
undercurrent in like particular i don't
know about other countries but in
american culture
that if you have money then you must
have deserved it somehow like you're
better
or you must have deserved it somehow i'm
like scientology is like exhibit a and
why that it's not true
[Laughter]
scientology was run on what was called
whales
well yeah whales are sucker donors
that'll give out stupid rich people
that won't just give all their money
hundreds of thousands of dollars
to be made into a wizard uh then they
started doing all these
real estate deals and they turned the
whole [ __ ] thing into an empire
it makes me so sad but they had whole
[ __ ] bases built to [ __ ] tom
cruise
now why is tom cruise in there first of
all i don't
i don't want to say some people say well
he must have been in there praying the
gay way
unanimously everybody says tom cruise is
not gay that's
john travolta probably john travolta
yeah yeah
well everybody who knows i have that i
mean i'm not saying
like any and like there's nothing wrong
with that i just wish he would come out
he's in the closet
i look my aunt was
she did like facials and hair and stuff
and in port orange and john travolta
used to have a house in port orange
and he used to come into her salon all
the time and everybody that worked in
that salon
and she told me my aunt told me she's
like that dude is gay as [ __ ]
gay [ __ ] everybody in the salon said
that tom
tom's straight i think what happened
with tom is when tom became a big star
people don't realize that tom is from
very humble origins
he claims that they cleared his they
cured him of dyslexia
i believe that something like that might
be true
but was it dyslexia or was it just a
really bad education maybe he couldn't
read too well
it doesn't mean that he is not tom
cruise is very intelligent
well dyslexia and intelligence are not
oriented
or the same thing like i said before
maybe illiteracy doesn't necessarily
mean
a person isn't intel no those are two
completely different things
because uh i knew a guy who was uh one
of my dad's friends was basically
functionally illiterate he ran a [ __ ]
multi-million dollar company but he
learned to read later
yeah that's what i mean
very humble backgrounds and hi sweetie
dropped out of school young and [ __ ]
was a [ __ ] problem child and never
learned to really read
um it comes with it comes anyway um
she's kidding i don't think he i don't
think his reading skills were real good
and i think they kind of completed his
education and he was already a famous
actor
he i think he wanted to be in the army
or do something military he didn't want
to pretend
to be a fighter pilot the hero he wanted
to be the real thing
but you can't do that when you're a
[ __ ] actor you can't i'm gonna leave
for [ __ ] three years and join the
army
but you can do the [ __ ] scientology
what you doing poop
stick in her butt come come down here
[Laughter]
you can see a little just a tail coming
up it's just a tail
i think she's like what i think tom
first of all got
class a treatment uh in scientology in
the church of scientology and i think
they gave him kind of a paramilitary
experience because
they do have a paramilitary wing called
the uh
the sea org and it's
bye pookie but um you know uh
sorry we're getting distracted pokey is
climbing all over the desk
scientology because l ron hubbard was a
naval commander
scientology is basically kind of like uh
set up like the navy they even wear
navy uniforms or at least the uh
the sea org does so uh was he a member
of the sea org
i don't think so who tom no
no i think he has the right to [ __ ]
wear a uniform though doesn't he
well they kind of let tom do whatever
[ __ ] he wants right
because he's tom imagine the navy
but it's mixed with the [ __ ] jedi
that's what they
that's what they think that they're
doing and they do have guns
they have guns ryan schwartz says the
tom cruise video where he says he's the
only one who could save people in an
accident exactly
exactly that made me if that made me
laugh and want to throw up
the scientologist knows what to do when
they see it and no one else
no one else does obviously see this this
is exactly what i'm talking about
exactly what i'm talking about
these types of people infuriate me yeah
and scientologists are like
infuriating but what's funny is that the
average scientologist is a dude that
joins a cult
and a dude that joins the cult is a
loser
yeah you're a [ __ ] larper i can't
get down with that just why why so
how messed up does your life have to be
yeah you're a loser you know
now a lot of scientologists that's not
going to make it scientology has been
around long enough to where
a lot of people that are in are born
into it
which is scary and that's the way
religions grow
okay oh my god so green is there
reproducing the religion grows where you
don't need to recruit new blood
read the book by a genus savage it's
called beyond belief it is the one of
the most horrifying things i have ever
read
she is the niece of david miscavige
and she was raised in the [ __ ] like she
was born in the church of scientology
she didn't know anything different but
she got the [ __ ] out when she was in her
20s
and it is horrifying i read some of it
to you didn't i because i was like
listen to this [ __ ]
problem is not so much scientology it's
the practices that they think that they
have to do
for certain things to happen they're
constantly on the verge of exercising a
[ __ ]
and their exorcisms might kill you i can
exercise i'm not gonna exercise
[ __ ] they lock you up in a
maximum security facility somewhere
yeah and they have brutal discipline
like the navy but they do it for life
and it's weird man they have a prison
compound
but they but if you were to go into
those prison compounds to free them they
wouldn't want to leave because it's
their religious choice to be there they
say yeah it's weird man
weird stuff but that's their they want
to do it whatever
yeah somebody said somebody said about
their remedy it's like i really do
recommend
um she is a former scientologist she
used to be in and she got out
and now she's made like a series
about it which is really good i've seen
like most of it i don't know if they've
done a new
yeah season but i saw like all of it up
to now
and it's like really really good a lot
of problems it's crazy [ __ ]
a lot of the problems with scientology i
think could be traced back to david
miscavige
he's kind of a brutal leader he's a
dictator
yeah of scientology calling chairman of
the board
c.o.b with a caller it wasn't like that
under l ron hubbard it's just that you
know when elrond when
when hubbard died yeah miss cabbage took
over
and he ran a he ran it in a kind of a
[ __ ] up way he was a timer
he's even his scientist dude
his dad says so man that dude is
i think eventually [ __ ] something
else scientology is not going away
it's gonna be here for a long long time
but i don't i think it will chill out
their membership has been declining yeah
happily it'll always be around i mean
they have a [ __ ] ton of money
yeah so you know they have that going
they have an empire of empty buildings
that's so weird we're little headsets so
you can listen to [ __ ] l ron
hubbard's [ __ ]
community seriously i'm just like so
it just it's one of the things i guess
because i experienced it personally and
i went through like almost a year of my
life was like dealing with this [ __ ]
when i didn't really want to and i just
because i just needed a [ __ ] paycheck
and like having to go every day
and like the first half hour of every
work day you had to go
in this like study room and like read
the brilliant master like elrond
hubbard's like [ __ ]
works they said like when you first
started working there and like i said i
needed a check so
don't judge me but um
you know they they made you sign a thing
they're like look we're not trying to
like we're scientologists we're not like
trying to convert you to our because i'm
sure their lawyers threw that [ __ ] up
we're not trying to convert you blahdy
blah but they were kind of on the dl
so they would make you go in first half
hour of every workday
from 8 30 to 9 or from 8 to 8 30 i don't
really remember
you had to go in the little study room
and you had to read
through l ron hubbard's uh you know
business courses you had to write essays
you had to like do tests you had to
because like seriously i didn't know
that much about scientology at the time
so i'm in there and i'm just like
writing [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm like
whatever
just like [ __ ] stop can i just please
do my job it's like what is this
[ __ ] because i don't like extraneous
you know
so i'm doing that and then i look in the
back and i see these two guys
and they're making [ __ ]
like little dudes out of clay yeah
they're postulating huh and they're like
like arguing with like talking to one
another and i'm like looking back going
oh
my god what the [ __ ] is going on
everything they do with little [ __ ]
clay
i'm like are you i'm like did i am i in
kindergarten again or
why are we talking to each other with
clay figures yeah
what is happening yeah so i asked
somebody like
i didn't say anything in there i get
back up to the office because like all
the other graphic designers that i
worked with were not scientologists one
of them was a jehovah's witness actually
um but the other two were atheists so
i'm talking to them like what the [ __ ]
why were they making people out of clay
i'm like i thought that i was like on a
[ __ ]
like kids show for a second and they
were like yeah um
their big thing is they think that you
can't just like
imagine stuff you have to like have
a physical representation if you have if
you're like mad at somebody
you have to like make a clay figure of
you
and make clay figure of the person that
you're mad at and then you have to like
pretend that you're like yeah there's
like a there's like a i think they call
it postulating isn't it yeah
or something i can't remember the word
there it's just
i was like really really this is my life
yeah they do [ __ ] oh my god
so i was just kind of everything is a
larp and over complicated and rehearsed
everything everything is kind of canned
and they constantly judge each other
based on their performance of how the
conversation went
it's it's making a big deal out of
nothing and trying to make
very basic everyday things
some kind of a [ __ ] performance
is what what it's trying to do exactly
is what they're trying to do
i was just kind of like and another
thing they did too
which another thing they did too which
drove me [ __ ] insane
was that like i said i'm a graphic
designer okay it's like we worked
the the company that i worked for i
can't remember what they were called
agent media corporation i don't think
they're in business anymore
but um it didn't have anything to do
with scientology it was basically like a
business to business
publishing company that had to do with
like the insurance um
industry like you were selling you were
basically selling insurance agents
like here's my package of like insurance
stuff like here's my life insurance
package my health insurance patch
so [ __ ] like that so we were doing like
direct mail [ __ ] like magazines crap
like that
so there was four of us in the graphic
design department and it's like
so we didn't have anything to do with
scientology but one thing that they were
very big on
was that they you had to
not only do your job but you also had to
like every single
task had a point value they had assigned
a point value to every single task that
you did in your job
everybody's job no matter what it was
and you had to keep track of all the
points that you accumulated during the
week
okay and you had to keep a chart like it
wasn't it wasn't enough
just to do your job and get the [ __ ]
done and get the magazine published get
the
you know direct mail uh packet done
that wasn't enough you also had to
accumulate all your points together and
at the end of the day on friday you had
to turn
in your points and then on monday
morning
you'd have a meeting and every single
person
had a chart and of your points
and if your points had gone up
and they would show everybody's chart
and if the chart was up everyone would
applaud
and then if the chart was down everyone
would just like be silent and like stare
at you in judgment
which i thought was the most ridiculous
pointless
stupid thing that i've ever had to
endure
and that's saying something working in
the corporate world
it just drove me [ __ ] crazy and
honestly like i'd only worked there like
a week or two before i figured out it's
like oh well they just want the [ __ ] to
go up every week so i'm just gonna make
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
which is what everyone else was doing
yeah so it's like
why can you take a break at all it was
no i'm fine
it was completely [ __ ] pointless
because everyone at the end of the week
would be like yeah um i made two more
points this week than last week
because nobody wanted everybody to like
stare at them at the monday morning
meeting like
oh you know the experts you didn't make
yeah constant growth they
expected that you would just keep going
up and up
and up like you could just go up forever
yeah
which i made the mistake one time
because i'm
kind of a sarcastic [ __ ] as you know
so i made the mistake of one of the
stupid essays that we had to write and i
made like a
snarky comment about how you could just
like keep going up forever like into
infinity
i don't remember exactly what i said but
i made like some smart ass comments
no they did not i was brought into the
office and had to explain myself
yeah and like it was just like
but yeah so after a while like after
eight months i was finally like i gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here and i just like
moved out of clear water entirely
because i was getting paranoid
clear water is owned by scientists i
couldn't even go to the grocery store
without thinking that
everybody was you explain clear water to
them scientology yeah it's like
that's like scientology central they
even [ __ ] control the police
basically more or less i mean they own a
lot of the real estate downtown
it's a beautiful place there's a beach
there's everything like that but i just
couldn't
after i worked there i just couldn't
live there anymore because i mean i just
had like a tiny apartment
but i just couldn't live there anymore
so we had to go off on that tangent
because jack parsons this [ __ ]
here
occult rocket scientist runs in
to lrh l ron hubbard one of the biggest
[ __ ] before he started science before
he started science one of the biggest
when he was just a sci-fi writer
and runs into as holiday
church of scientology
was the most successful he's the one
that had all the bank that dude had
[ __ ] a lot of money well yeah
later on i mean i guess he wasn't he
died oh green to toot this [ __ ]
he wasn't stupid but all the people that
follow him are clearly stupid
i was just like i don't i don't have any
patience for that kind of stuff
scientology was pre-internet information
was hard to find
difficult to debunk [ __ ] no so what's
people's excuse nowadays no
no uh well it's because it's been there
for so long now well it's been around a
long time it's got to be true
it's a ufo basically um
but you couldn't check couldn't fact
check anything back then people kind of
had
paranormal beliefs it was more common
and uh he evidently put on a great show
everybody liked him
i think that had a lot to do with it was
just his charisma people liked him
i don't know why even though he had that
weird mouth he had a weird mouth and he
can't get past the mouth it was a
different era there's a different time
well you gotta understand that
he's always putting his like poking his
lips out his
audience it's brilliant it was not a
very sophisticated audience
you know and um it was just another time
and they were already kind of larping
you know so they're just
lapping it up he's kind of trying to
sell them powers of the mind
and they didn't know everything that he
believed also that's another thing
yeah he didn't find that out to like ota
and everybody's like ah
i don't know i've always been like ever
since i can remember i've always been
like a really big
skeptic of anything
that was like you know just do this
thing it'll make your life better do
this
i'm always like really skeptical of that
it's a science fiction writer so like i
said that's why
i don't think i could ever be like
persuaded to join a cult because
i'm just like immediately like somebody
comes at me with
hey like do this one thing and make your
life better i'm like no
no no i'm not doing that so
you know i don't know i'm like i'll
figure my own [ __ ] out thank you
but so yeah so jack parsons meets l ron
hubbard
before el ron hubbard started
scientology i guess he didn't get that
idea until later
so i don't know if it was jack parsons
idea or if it was i'll run hubbard's
idea
but one of the things that they thought
they were gonna do
so they think they're gonna do this
ritual
that's going to summon the goddess
babylon to earth who is kind of like
your idealized
woman um they called her the scarlet
woman which i guess is kind of like the
um
that's kind of like the the symbol like
in a lot of different belief systems for
like
you know free love or you know a woman
that's
you know not like past religions
kind of thing so they're trying to like
have a ritual to bring this woman to
earth apparently
so they have this ritual there's like
some chanting
like some occult symbols they're drawing
in the air with swords
uh they're dripping animal blood on the
runes
they're jerking off uh on various
things you know it's like the
masturbatory kind of magic
so you know they're attempting to bring
this woman
to fruition now
one thing that did happen that was
interesting was that not too long after
they did this
um this chick showed up that actually
jack parsons ended up marrying later on
i think that he had the perception that
she was the woman that he had
that they called that yeah yeah she
didn't know it at the time because she
just happened to turn up it was just a
coincidence
but he was just like oh you must be
babylon
earthly form that's right i was thinking
about
anton levay anton levay didn't meet jack
parsons
no that's what that's why i didn't know
what you were talking about because tom
levay
met el ron hubbard later because i
remember there was a levate
hubbard connection if i remember
correctly
yes i can't remember i think i thought
there was
i mean it was like i said i i don't
really remember i think it was later
though
yeah 70s yeah
okay it might have been i think so yeah
so they do all this [ __ ]
now what ron hubbard ends up doing
he not only steals
jack parsons then girlfriend who as
you'll remember
was the very young sister of his former
wife
uh you know sarah northrup now elrond
hubbard eventually ended up marrying her
later on but he took off with the
girlfriend
he also got jack parsons to invest
almost 21 000 in a quote-unquote
boat business yeah his idea was that
they were gonna buy
like three yachts i think it was and
they were gonna like buy them and like
refurbish them and resell them
okay but what ended up happening was
that l ron hubbard bought the boats
and then took the [ __ ] off yeah so he
basically
made off with a bunch of jack parsons
money so you can go
found [ __ ] scientology and then yeah
and those boats would eventually be
the foundation of the sea org in
scientology later on
so this is where that connection is now
jack parsons ended up having to
sue elm ron hubbard yeah
and sarah northrup his former girlfriend
who would later go on to mary over on
hubbard
to get some of the money back but i
think all that he got back was
maybe like less than three thousand out
of the almost twenty one thousand that
he now the books
one of them wasn't the free wins was it
i don't know it might have been
because he did end up but he did
actually do what he said he was going to
do he did
actually end up buying boats with the
money yeah but
it was supposed to be a business like
him and jack parsons were supposed to go
busy
it was an investment but he just took
the money
bought the boats and then took the [ __ ]
off see scientology has a shift
it's called the free wins yeah and that
was the one lrh he commanded it when he
when he had to go hide he'd go out on
the freewinds yeah because it's like
you can't do anything about it i don't
think anybody's [ __ ] taking it
anywhere in a long long time but they
still owe it oh
it's like one of their religious relics
but it's like a roach infested old
[ __ ] ship
yeah yeah it's it's i was probably nice
back in the day but
well you know most people most things
are like i guess
all kinds of weird [ __ ] happened on that
ship too locking people up down the
bilge and
down the bilge pumps and [ __ ]
overnight honestly like i said i'm not
big on conspiracy theories but
honestly anything you tell me about
scientology i'll probably believe it
evidently they had all kinds of weapons
because they would go out to
international waters they had some
[ __ ] surface-to-air missiles
probably stinger missiles or red eye in
this probably red-eye missiles
yeah hand loft [ __ ] and a bunch of
machine guns and stuff that was
evidently
but who knows if that's true the fbi
thought that
yeah yeah the fbi thought they had all
kinds of [ __ ] out there on it
because you know um because the thing
about it like one of the company that i
used to work for
you know the woman that i mean the
scientologist got in trouble
for murdering or i don't know if they
they didn't charge them with murder but
it was more like negligent homicide
lisa mcpherson yeah she used to work
at the company that i worked for in
clearwater yeah and
one of the she was the finance manager
or
something like that she was one of the
managers was her roommate
and several of the managers and like
people in higher positions there had
actually testified at her trial which i
didn't find out until a couple months
after i started working there
which again disturbed me a lot because
like i said i'm not into conspiracy
theories but scientologists are so crazy
that anything that they do
like if you would tell me anything they
do like they killed this person or they
had this person killed
i would probably buy that [ __ ] because
those are exactly the kinds of people
back when we would ever [ __ ] do a
show about scientology in the comments
section of be a bunch of people going oh
i believe in freedom of religion [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i'm getting i'm out of here
all these people are crazy
that's scientologists scientology
[ __ ]
well they're very transparent they're
not very interested
yeah they're all over the internet and
[ __ ] they try to turn everybody
against you if you're talking bad about
them
but i think they gave up scientology
tried to beat the internet
they had a war against the internet
which is hilarious they didn't know what
the internet because they were so
behind so behind the [ __ ] like as
technology they thought they were going
to drive every
all the [ __ ] uh what they call sps
off the
suppressive person yeah they can drive
all the sps all right off the net
yeah they won't be here anymore didn't
work out that way they didn't know what
the internet
was that's what i mean it's 70s i mean
they were still using
fax machines for fun sake 10x 10x
yeah in the 2000s in the late 2000s
well lrh told them to do it by telex so
that's what they did
so that's what they did yeah so they
really thought
access they didn't really get into the
internet until like after
everybody had already caught on to that
[ __ ] so it's like they were like several
years behind and they still
thought that they were gonna be able to
i mean i don't know about nowadays but
for a while
they would still like if somebody said
something against them
they would still like put up a website
saying that you were a child molester or
something like
and everybody was so on to it yeah but
they didn't realize that everyone was
onto it which is like really funny
inspire your neighborhood and say how
bad you were
show up at your door yeah somebody's
mentioning it there is there is a good
movie about
now ron hubbard they couldn't say that
it was about l ron hubbard because they
don't want to get sued
it's called the master yeah and
it's good it's a real good movie and it
basically tells the story
and like i said i think elrond hubbard
was an interesting guy
he didn't really do anything wrong he
was just a founder of this [ __ ] weird
ass religion
they like the the cultists liked him
that's the only thing that matters i
don't give a [ __ ]
if you're in a cult if you like it then
fine all right
he wasn't hurting anybody and
it wasn't until later towards the end
times of the l ron hubbard era
when he was getting kind of old that
weird thing started happening in the
church and then
when miscavige took over it started to
get brutal
but during l ron hubbard's time there
aren't any reports of any kind of abuse
everybody seemed to like him
he was a weird dude interesting guy yeah
uh
and he was a huckster he was a huster
yeah yeah oh yeah big time
oh yeah but as far as i way i see it
he was in a way selling entertainment
these are larpers yeah even the people
joining the cult are larping
you know they're hoping that it's true
but i don't think they cared whether or
not it was actually true they just liked
the activity well people just like the
actor and they like like
feeling like they're part of yeah and i
think that had a lot i get that i don't
have that feeling
but um they have it i don't get it but
okay if if other people want to do it
it'd be like they're playing dungeons
and dragons but it's real life
i guess yeah all right so i'm gonna go
to the bathroom
i'll also babysit the kids you gotta
babysit i'm on babysit go ahead
okay
okay all right so what's up with
everybody
how much were the cults fees uh a lot
to get anything out what they would do
is they would
bilk you constantly if you
were taking courses from them you had to
pay thousands of dollars for some kind
of course
and then they would show up to your
house and say look there's an emergency
going on
you've got to help us you got to donate
to the church we have to stop this
and it'd be some kind of [ __ ] cause
you know the psychiatrists are taking
over the drug in the kids or
we have to build this new radio station
that will broadcast the [ __ ] truth to
everybody
it was like any other [ __ ] religion
where they're constantly trying to
get you to finance their efforts to save
the world uh but then they'd take the
money and they'd buy
[ __ ] used [ __ ] and try to make okay
here's a weird
okay here's a good example of what they
tried to do
or what they did do they built millions
of dollars
out of wales which are don't you know
people that donated to the church
to buy the ability to
print cds all right and they were going
to make cds with all the [ __ ]
holy scriptures you know veil ron
hubbard on it and they were going to
give those out
i guess for free and to help save the
world
but they were doing this in the 2000s at
a time where cd technology was just like
a thing of the past
and the equipment to make to
mass-produce these cds was
it was all used it was used equipment
they were going to use
so they made millions and millions of
dollars off their parishioners
to make this [ __ ] cds and then they
would make runs and then they would
[ __ ] build more money on them
we need uh hundreds of thousands of
dollars to make use of cds
and they would make millions of cds and
the cities would just sit there
but they weren't they didn't give a [ __ ]
about the cds they just wanted to get
the money out of the parishioners
yeah and then they bought a [ __ ]
television studio
an old hollywood television studio they
had thing all decked out they made the
parishioners buy all that [ __ ]
of course they pocketed most of the
money well yeah yeah
and now they have a television studio in
the era of [ __ ] youtube and they were
doing this so they did this
like they started a channel right yeah
they have a channel nobody's seen this
[ __ ] channel where is this channel
i mean it's on the cable it's on cable
but nobody's watching that
well no unless they're watching it like
to be
like for a joke like you make fun of it
and you you say well that's crazy that's
millions and millions of dollars we're
telling they made money off of it
from the parishioners not that not the
channel the channel doesn't make money
the channels loses money
they could have done the same thing with
the [ __ ] youtube channel
all right that's what they but they
wouldn't have been able to raise
millions of dollars to start a youtube
channel
yeah okay that's the difference so the
idea
scientology runs by bilking
scientologists yeah it's a pyramid
scheme exactly
i mean you almost made me want to watch
the scientology channel
except not i probably would not because
i don't have candy ass
after like 10 minutes i'd probably be
like throwing chips very very candy-ass
mainstream fluff corporate
commercial that's what it's like
watching how wonderful everything is and
they can save your
that they're gonna that they're gonna
save you it's like
it's worse than christianity worse than
chris honestly though
i kind of wish if i didn't have a
conscience which i do yeah but um
i kind of wish i had thought of that
[ __ ] like back in the 90s or
back when people were still dumb enough
to fall for it
i kind of wish i had like kind of and
then i could have made a few million
dollars i could retire you know what i
mean i've been nice
but i don't know i can't bring myself to
do that kind of [ __ ]
i'm plus i'm not good at
bullshitting so if you're poor you can't
join them no
no no they don't want poor people they
don't want poor people if you're poor
you cannot be a scientologist
they only want rich bilbo baggins
looking [ __ ] in their [ __ ]
50s and 60s that'll fall for this stupid
[ __ ]
it's alarming how many people that
actually have money
yeah are dumb enough to fall for this
[ __ ] i guess it's not that alarming it's
like nothing well they make all kinds of
promises that they can cure any disease
they can reverse aging give you
superpowers give you psychic powers
if you're going blind restore sight
everything every [ __ ] thing
anything can thank you thank you very
much
you're saying that read what it says
it's a mind over matter cult i'd love
you to do a show critiquing the
selection process for various special
forces units around the world
oh they're all going to be about the
same well now they're not going to be
the same
[Laughter]
and it's also going to be uh era
dependent like what they're doing now i
don't know it's
the standards are going to be a lot
easier today than they used to be
because
they gave the order to make more special
forces troops here in the united states
which the only way to make more would be
to lower the standards
during the time i was in it was near
impossible to be to to get into sf i
only knew one dude that did it
and he was liking a a professional
athlete if he looked at him
i didn't realize it at the time but i
was looking at a guy who was on
anabolics um but evidently there
there's a lot more of them now they're
not as special as they used to be
because the battlefields changed
same thing back in vietnam it was hard
to get good people so
the special forces of the vietnam era
they did bad ass [ __ ]
but they were kind of regular looking
guys when i was in during the 90s
it was hard to get special forces it was
a select brotherhood the last thing that
they did was
want new special forces guys it was real
small
um you wanted to get in there because
when you got out
would you first of all an sf guy during
the time i was in there [ __ ] made a
hundred thousand a year
all right that's an active duty yeah 100
000. and then when you got out you'd
make 150
000 in private security you know so
it was the beginning of a [ __ ] long
career that kind of [ __ ]
it's changed though now
you know um you can make a lot of you a
lot of money doing private contracting
as long as you have that dd214 that said
you served especially if it's infintry
you can go anywhere now make all kinds
of money you don't make money in the
army anymore you make money when you get
out
yeah yeah but uh the difficulty level
goes up and down i'd probably say
over the years the hardest one to get
into
the most [ __ ] the one that's probably
the most sketchiest
over the years would have been the ffl
french foreign legion
pretty [ __ ] sketchy kind of badasses
though it's kind of like being a maximum
security prison
there are people i haven't heard that
yet yeah ffl
are they special forces no but they are
special
we're all special it's tough it's
real tough it's real tough um but part
of the toughness is uh
they're in the field a lot they're
[ __ ]
kept away from mainstream society
they're
they don't get paid much they they do a
lot of suffering they're living outside
most a lot of times it's just you know
i'm kind of drunk
no i'm kind of drunk you don't say yeah
i'm kind of drunk too but
look out you wanna make another one yeah
okay holy crap this
is this is well i'm not gonna say it's
unprecedented because i think i did it
last week too thank you very much again
oh my gosh i'm just like
i'm so appreciative you guys this is
awesome
some stories a few drunken rants mixed
in it is a show after all
you know how this [ __ ] goes when we get
liquor inside
but yeah yeah so
like i said so jack mars jack parsons
and l ron hubbard decide
that they're not only gonna so the
ritual that they
uh started doing was called babylon
working
because like i said babylon was the name
not with a y but with an a
and that was like the name of the
goddess that they were going to uh
bring to earth i guess now also because
aleister crowley had written this book
called
moonchild in 1917. so this gave them the
idea
that spiritually
i guess like mating with this
babylon goddess would produce
spiritually
the moon child not a real baby like i
said but like kind of a spiritual baby
and that was the baby that was going to
go to space someday or something
i'm not real clear strong you be careful
with that okay thank you because you
will get [ __ ] up on that
so i'm getting her [ __ ] up people
we'll see what kind of show it is when
she can barely talk
well you know i'm the one that's got to
read the note i can still read so i'm
doing okay i think we're in the third
hour
uh no we're at two hours and 28 minutes
and 14 seconds all right how much
material we have left um
uh it's probably like two thirds good so
like i said so they're trying to
metaphorically give birth to the moon
child
yeah with the goddess babylon like i
said i don't think this is an
actual thing but it's a spiritual thing
because like who wants a real baby yeah
you know what i mean i i feel like that
was kind of where they were coming from
so
you would have had my real baby back if
we had been together in the baby having
years and the baby yeah
yeah there's a certain time where you're
young and dumb and fertile enough
i'm too old for that [ __ ] right now
you're like yeah i'm 25 let's have a
baby you know
[ __ ] you know but when you get into
your [ __ ] 40s and 50s you're like i'm
too tired for that [ __ ] tired i don't
want to wake up for that
we have a cat
[Laughter]
this tastes like tequila is this tequila
oh man did i put tequila in that
taste that that tastes like i may have
made you a [ __ ] sunrise i mean i'll
drink it i don't care but you know what
i mean
that tastes like tequila right that's
tequila that's tequila i told you that's
a tequila sunrise yes it is
i grabbed it without thinking oh well
it'll well it'll make me drink it slower
okay
anyway talk about me being drunk you
don't even know what liquor you're
boring that's too cool they were sitting
right there next to each other and i was
you know i just grabbed what i drank
put it on there it's sticky i wasn't
thinking
oh i'm gonna have such a headache
tomorrow no no i'm gonna like i'm gonna
down
that's silver tequila that's real close
i mean silver tequila
is the mexican vodka anyway
it's the mexican vodka he's always
trying to talk me into [ __ ] why you
always trying to talk me other [ __ ]
that's what i do i'm like the joe rogan
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] alcohol i met joe rogan trying
to talk joe rogan can't talk me into
anything either i should have seen him
all [ __ ]
fear factor you sit there and talk girls
into eating [ __ ] cave crickets and
[ __ ] yeah you're not attacking me
you're not going you could do it it's
okay nothing to eat in caves i'd be like
no
no picking up spiders and eating them
it's only 500 500
eat the spider you eat spider 500 no
it's like the kind of dude that would
talk your girlfriend into [ __ ] doing
porn or something
no [ __ ] back on [ __ ] robin because
that's like seriously that's my
that's my go-to answer and everything
just no i'm not doing it
and i'm seriously not eating bugs thank
you very much thank you very much stop
propaganda topping
we don't care about no topics i try to
stay on the topic
oh man i was talking about the topic
when you went in there oh man
and made me a drink with tequila instead
of everybody's drink as [ __ ] saturday
saturday end of the world pandemic we
can't go with a man
action talking i'm talking your asses
through the [ __ ] pandemic
through the apocalypse kind of a boring
apocalypse
we'll see we'll see what happens you
know what i mean we'll see what happens
it's all right though i'm gonna go a
mega man on this [ __ ]
well the thing about it is that i mean
we worked at home anyway yeah so we were
already ready we were
already kind of at home a lot anyway
our weird asses couldn't get real jobs
we had to figure out [ __ ] internet
jobs
long before everybody else i mean well
the weird thing about
and you know my real job is about [ __ ]
you guys don't even [ __ ]
don't worry about what i did for real
[ __ ]
you know what's weird though i never
really like as weird
i don't look that weird but i mean i
used to have like
you know my head shaved and it used to
be like dyed bright red and purple and
stuff
i never really had that many problems
finding jobs that was because the way
you carried yourself
because i was good at what i did and
plus i was in a creative field
i was a graphic designer so they kind of
expected you to be a little weird so it
wasn't
that off-putting right and plus i never
really applied the job so like really
square like uptight kind of places
so i never really had that much the
pandemic just [ __ ] ushered our world
into reality all right they're all
having to become like us we were ahead
of the curve a couple years
in a way it's like it sucks like that
people are dying of the [ __ ] and it's
like i don't want people getting sick
and everything but in some ways
it's kind of like it's just a natural i
was working on the internet anyway
yeah and natural part of the less that i
have to interact with other people
like in person the better it is
honestly so i'm just kind of just let's
see how it goes
you know so it's all right i'm not
really bothered that much i do
like to go out and interact with people
in person
that's the only thing i miss honestly i
don't miss going to a job i really don't
i always hated that
um but that's i do miss like going out
and dancing and seeing our friends and
i miss i'm glad i don't have bosses
anymore
guys or commanders if i ever have to do
that no more
no more you know so i'm in my own army
now
ever since i was a kid i've never liked
being told what to do you know what i
mean
i was just because i was always kind of
like look i'll figure it out okay
just like back on back the [ __ ] off i
always had pretty much i pretty much
always had good commanders
so i don't want any command whatever
they told me to do is because that would
keep us alive and get to get the mission
done so
okay cool that's just you know we're
just giving you the information like
they're giving you the information so
you get roger that i got we got this
that's you know i'm always like yeah
i'll figure it out i didn't really like
civilian jobs you know that's why i was
such a good salesman man [ __ ] in in
in the corporate world where they just
as an independently contracted salesman
they just go here you sell it you're the
man
because i was like my own job of my own
boss yeah you got to go out and do your
own
thing yeah i just went out did my own
[ __ ] thing which is like i said i'm
so
[ __ ] happy that the internet came
along and i could just like i could
write my books we could do our show
right you know i can do my graphic
design i don't have to see anybody i can
just do everything
like over [ __ ] text or email it's
fantastic
and now we're just making money [ __ ]
disseminating information
and entertainment to y'all and among
on a global [ __ ] on a global scale
isn't that neat
yeah like i said [ __ ] modern
technology has caught up with us
you know it's i know people like to like
go doom and gloom and everything like
that
but in a lot of ways like this is really
facilitated
i mean think how [ __ ] cool this is
it's gonna work out the pandemic sucks
i'm not saying that but if this [ __ ] if
the p what if the pandemic had happened
before the internet
think how [ __ ] catastrophic and it's
catastrophic enough
as it is but think how catastrophic it
would have been
if people couldn't go to school online
or work online or do all that [ __ ]
it's like it would have been way way way
worse i think how wait
theo think of how catastrophic it had
been if it had a 20
mortality rate well like i said
dead bodies would be stacked up at the
end of the [ __ ] block yeah you
couldn't [ __ ] bury him fast
the mortality rate isn't that high in
this i think yeah but like
i was just reading an article earlier
like they've done some studies in europe
that um even if you just get a mild case
or even an asymptomatic case um eighty
percent
of those that they looked at had lasting
heart damage
which is not i believe the [ __ ] when i
see it i'm just saying that was like uh
are they talking about people in their
80s no they're talking about
everyone that had it they're talking
about i believe there's a lot of
weaponized information out there
i'm just saying i'm just i'm just saying
that they're that they don't know
because they don't know a lot about this
so
they're trying to sell vaccines a lot a
lot of the a lot the the medical
industry is involved in a lot of this
you just can't believe everything until
you see it i don't believe
authority this kind of authority right
but
like i said i don't believe a lot of
random i don't believe a lot of randos
on youtube either
right but we're rando's on youtube but
i'm not telling you that you have to
believe anything we
say either because we're just like drunk
and rambling about whatever
so we're just a fun show
i'm not sure i i'm not trying to be like
i've worked with doctors that have told
me [ __ ]
i can't believe you made a drink with
tequila yeah well whatever
i don't even like money makes the world
go around and a lot of times they tell
you what's going to make them the most
money
but let's get back to the show right so
all right so so they do this [ __ ] now
apparently they okay so they do this
ritual where they thought
that they had successfully summoned the
goddess
i'm not really sure if this random woman
showing up that parsons ended up
marrying later
was like the culmination of that so he
thought okay cool it worked out or
whatever
or if it was something else but they
thought that it was successful so they
were like okay well we can sell
the mansion now the parsonage so they
sell the mansion
to developers for 25 000 which i guess
was a lot of money back then
but they said under the stipulation
that him and the the new girlfriend
could live in the coach house right
so the people that had been meeting at
the lodge or whatever they had to meet
somewhere else because like i said
they'd been having the meetings at this
mansion that parsons had so
as i mentioned earlier parsons invested
almost 21 thousand dollars
in this quote-unquote boat company
with elrond hubbard and his former
girlfriend and
former sister-in-law sarah northrop
this is messed up you guys um so they
were gonna do this thing and like i said
elrond hubbard did
purchase the yachts i believe he bought
three of them
but he had no intention evidently of
you know getting jack parsons in on that
[ __ ] like in on the business he was just
gonna take the money
and take off so that's pretty much what
happened
so apparently without jack parsons
knowing about it
l ron hubbard had requested permission
from the navy
to go from uh he was going to go to
china
and then he was going to go to south
america and central america
and he was basically just going around
the world
and just like taking off with
jack parsons money yeah so that's
basically what he was doing so
they they leave for miami they've got
they've got ten thousand dollars
of jack parsons money um
jack was kind of like what the [ __ ] but
he calls them and um is like what it's
totally fine man it's like we're not
doing anything it's like everything is
all cool and jack was like okay
fine but then you know
they he figured out later on that that
wasn't
what it was and he and eventually ended
up uh taking them
to court i think he only got 2 900
of his money back um which
kind of sad now the thing about it is
that l ron hubbard
ended up marrying sarah northrup but he
was already married to another woman
at the time margaret grubbs so that was
some bigamy right there
yeah so you know yeah there wasn't a big
penalty for that though
yeah that's why he did it he said [ __ ]
if they catch me what do they do
[Laughter]
i can marry all the women yes what's
gonna happen you gonna give me two weeks
in jail
it amazes me that l ron hubbard found
more than one woman willing to marry
that mountain by all accounts he was an
entertaining guy
and mouse and he had a funny [ __ ]
mouth
i can't
that's the thing like if it's kind of a
slimer
you know i mean like he constantly had
spit in his mouth well he definitely
came across
to me and like i said i never met the
person i never met him in person
obviously but he always came across like
in videos of him
he always just comes across like a
creeper yeah so
i mean if i'd met him and i was just
like i would just be like
transfixed yeah by the way weird mouth
and i'd just be like i just when i was a
kid
i remember guys like that there were
lots of guys like that
it was a like i said it was another era
it was pre-internet
if a guy could talk up a [ __ ] storm
people people would believe it you know
what i mean he'd get attention
so there were you know he wasn't the
only one that was like that there there
was a whole
genre of dudes like that that would sit
there and just [ __ ]
i love the fact that there's talking
types of dudes that are a genre yeah
it's like a genre [ __ ] sit
there just a genre of
he would just talk his way up your slime
slimy dudes whose
mouths look like buttholes yeah
like fish buttholes he was the kind of
guy that would [ __ ] talk up a [ __ ]
big storm and maybe mesmerize you into
believing that [ __ ]
you know i mean that's that's what he
was see i don't think i'm mesmerizable
in that fashion
you're a modern person yeah it's a lot
harder
you have access to information also i'm
kind of like yeah
and you're skeptical about certain
things yeah some people want to believe
certain things and this is a time
where women got married to dudes who
were the breadwinners
so they had a hard time judging who was
full of [ __ ] and who wasn't
and if a guy could come along and he
goes oh i'm gonna do this and that and
she's seeing dollar signs going he can
take care of me
well that's what was going on in a way
that's like really shitty because that's
kind of like a
women back then didn't have a lot of
choices yeah but it's like
that you you were expected to marry
early like at least
when you got out of high school or when
you got out of college like in your
early 20s
and you needed somebody that could
support you because you didn't really
have a lot of options for supporting
yourself which was kind of sucks well
you
do all women always work that's another
[ __ ] thing they always
work it's just that they never really
became rich thank you
all right thank you very much i love
attention
they never really became rich and they
still women
tend to not become rich today either all
right
for i don't know a bunch of different
factors i guess but if you looked at l
ron hubbard he did become rich
so if you did think he was a good cat
cat you'd have been right
he swindled his way and talked his way
into [ __ ] tens of millions of dollars
so yeah that [ __ ] slimy ass [ __ ]
mouth that he had was gold it's just
that it took time
dude i kind of feel like maybe
some of the women that were into it were
thinking to themselves
well this guy kind of seems like a slime
ball
yeah but other people are buying into it
but he's rich and if he goes to prison
maybe i'll get his money there's all
different kinds of angles i mean
like i'm looking at it don't assume that
women are dumb they're just kind of like
coming at it like
this dude's like really irritating but
if i could put up with him until he goes
to jail
maybe i could guess i'm looking at it
even before that i'm looking at it
i'm looking at it in the proto phases
before he's had money
he's sitting there talking up a storm a
lot of women might have looked at him
and went
he's full of [ __ ] all right but that
dude's gonna go far because other people
believe it
yeah he is kind of other people are
obviously other people are believing in
this
[ __ ] and then he's [ __ ] there was a
crowd building up around him
yeah i mean he was coming up with coming
up with [ __ ] ideas that made money
that other people wanted
so they they you know hitched they
hitched a ride on him
well and like i said back in the day you
kind of had to put up with
what you had to put out with what you
had put up with and then you wouldn't
know
much you know what i mean the [ __ ]
the mass media wasn't as developed as
you have now there's no social media
you couldn't go on [ __ ] tinder you
know what i mean [ __ ] it was a
different situation
like i said thank [ __ ] christ for the
internet oh my god
i don't even believe in that [ __ ] but
thank god for the internet thank you
very much
thank you very much thank you thank you
do i get another shirt give me give me
give me
[Laughter]
what one do you want like someone we'll
send you another one
we can do another one we have a liquid
we have some extras um thomas carlos
have you guys heard of robert anton
wilson yes i have
um he actually ended up writing about he
might be one of the main reasons why
jack parsons kind of had a little bit of
a renaissance
later on because robert anton wilson uh
wrote about him
because like i said you know jack
parsons was kind of in with not only the
rocket scientists but he was also with a
lot of sci-fi writers
uh like robert heinlein and stuff yeah
so you know he was kind of in that scene
so it you know it might be in like i
said robert antoine
yeah here's just something else we're
talking about a totally different era
we remember all these names like they're
legendary
if these guys were appearing today
they'd be totally unknown
these guys could not exist in the air
the modern era of social media
they wouldn't be able to compete against
it well there's just so
there's too much there's too much yeah
let's say you had l ron hubbard appear
now
and he's doing [ __ ] and he's on
youtube
he'd be laughed at yeah he'd be laughed
at
they go that's a funny-looking
[ __ ] he'd be compared to other
guys who are like him at this at this
period
and there'd be more there'd be other
guys that were better than him
he'd lose out it just happened to be
that he appeared
in that place in that time and
there the public didn't have any
defenses against him that'd be a good
way to well
it was easier to stand easier back then
back then right i mean
um nowadays you really have to do
something you're super excited you've
got to be on your game
because everybody right i mean like i
said
it's a double-edged sword i mean the
good thing about the internet
is that it democratizes um
entertainment it democratized like
anybody that's creative
can make their own right um you know
content
and that's awesome right but you got to
compete but it's also much harder
to kind of you know make yourself stand
out from
the fray thank you bro bunya punter oh
my god you are a champion
you were a champion a private message
extra large well no i have i have their
address
yeah because he was one of the ones that
we sent what model before
um yeah like what because i think i sent
you
i sent you a logo one like this one and
i also i think i might have also sent
him a blissken one
okay but we can do uh i have a whale in
the industry and i have a [ __ ]
uh i have this one i'm going to make you
tony
i'm going to make a tyrell one okay yeah
even though like i said tyrone we had
the idea to do the tyrell one with the
owl and everything even though a bunch
of other people have done a design like
that
but i think i can maybe do okay a better
one
all right than the ones that i've seen
all right i mean not to be snotty or
anything
i mean some of the ones that i've seen
are nice but i could probably do it okay
i'm just saying
[Laughter]
so all right so
right about the time of uh the cold war
you know emerging got your
red scare kind of [ __ ] you get your
weyland industries
yeah i got a wayland one we have two of
those we've got this it's the same size
we have that
is wayland yeah we have a whalen
weyland corporation and one that has
says weyland yutani
so um yeah so you have your house
un-american activities
committee so they're starting to
investigate people that have
perceived communist sympathies
and uh jack parsons comes up on their
radar like i said
i believe the fbi had been watching jack
parsons since the 1940s
he certainly believed that they were
watching him and i really don't have any
reason to doubt it because
they thought because aleister crowley
was being
watched they definitely thought that
um aleister crowley's group was
subversive
and um because they were into free love
they were into
women's equality they were into other
things so it's like they were
kind of watching them as well because
they thought they were a degenerate
influence
so because he was involved with them
they he started uh they started watching
him as well
so um at this point they
kind of like ramped up i guess their
uh surveillance of him and he
ended up uh losing like a lot of his
uh colleagues that he had worked with
previously ended up losing their
security clearances and their jobs
um and also this was very weird to me i
guess this wouldn't happen nowadays
but in the fbi's file of
jack parsons they actually listed him as
quote unquote possibly bisexual which is
like a weird thing to like
think that the fbi would like in this
day and age it seems very strange
that the fbi would like put that in
their [ __ ] [ __ ] about you
but i mean i don't i don't know
i don't think that he was particularly
bisexual i think there was one dude that
said that yeah we had like a
you know a homosexual relationship like
back in the whenever
but honestly he was seen as more of like
a womanizer
and you know like his dad was and he
kind of like got it like was into orgies
and he was like super into women and
stuff
so i don't really know like he may have
been bisexual i don't really know
but it's just very weird to me that the
fbi would like
put that in their [ __ ] report about
him i don't know
different era like i said thank you very
much janet oh my goodness
thank you very much oh that's so awesome
i love that little cartoon
is he an avocado he's an avocado
so yeah so they accuse him of like
quote-unquote
sexual perversion because of his
affiliation with the oto
and aleister aleister crowley
so and like i said they're all getting
their security clearances revoked
um you know because of their
association with aleister crowley
because of their association with
leftist politics
um which was a big no-no at the time
um it and it seems like jack parsons
he had written some he had done some
political writings later on i don't
believe that they were published until
after uh he died but
i mean he was not a communist i mean
he was very
he he was uh had some marxist ideas he
had some socialist ideas
he was very um morally opposed to
nazis i mean one of the reasons that he
was getting
into rocketry and getting into all that
stuff was specifically to fight against
the nazis
and um you know one of his colleagues
particularly was like you know let's
[ __ ] kill these fascists let's do
this on the other so they were very into
that
but it does seem like he kind of
you know as much as he kind of flirted
with communist ideas earlier on
he really didn't go all in with that
um even though the fbi did still
perceive him as being a danger i guess
so before you go on too much about the
fbi
let me just say on a side note later on
l ron hubbard in a church of scientology
scientology
launched something called operation snow
white i believe what it was called yes
it was
which was the largest infiltration
of the fbi in [ __ ] history it was as
far as i know it still is yes
scientology
infiltrated fbi to find out all their
[ __ ] secrets yep
but whether really they want to know the
secrets about scientology it was because
lrh was so paranoid about the fbi he
wanted to know what they knew about it
weird yeah snow white operation snow
white
but went down in history so even though
these guys are kind of [ __ ] misfits
they got [ __ ] done it's weird it's
really weird yeah
that's quite big takes quite a bit of
power to infiltrate the fbi
just keep sending that people at him
just keep sending people at him to
[ __ ] get jobs
eventually they get jobs the fbi can
find out anything that's what's weird
those fbi agents were loyal to [ __ ]
scientology not the fbi
weird yeah i mean i kind of feel like i
don't know i think people have a
perception
you have a perception that was the fbi
or the government or whatever that it's
like this one big
you know monolithic structure but it's
not it's just like a bunch of offices
which are like regular [ __ ] people
just like every other
like workplace so i feel like
you know there's a lot of maybe this
upsets some people but there's like a
lot of gaps there where
if you can pretend good enough you can
just get a job there like a regular
person
and if you had nefarious intent yeah
you could totally just get in there and
be like yeah i just want a job here
security and then check though well yeah
but it's like if you hadn't done
anything like
in your previous life nobody yeah it's
weird
it's weird that their relatives didn't
mention that they were part of this
church of scientology
maybe they got everybody to like [ __ ]
go because they used to go ask
they usually go [ __ ] interview
everybody who knows you and everybody
who's related to you
yeah but you know like i said maybe
nobody knew
or maybe they got people to lie for them
or
i don't think it's as hard as people
think i mean if you can get a few people
to like [ __ ]
say it's gonna be harder today i just do
uh well nowadays yeah
because nowadays you know they can check
everything they can check every [ __ ]
facebook post you ever made
every everything so back then
much harder they could just go to google
and [ __ ] buy all your information and
everything about you
yeah no porn you were watching right
what porn you were watching everything
you ever bought off
amazon so it's like you know back then
it was much easier
to get away with [ __ ] nowadays i don't
think you could
nowadays you make one [ __ ] bad tweet
and everybody knows about that [ __ ] so
yeah
so at this point so like i said um you
know he's getting in trouble with fbi a
bunch of his like former colleagues are
getting like
blackballed um because of their
political beliefs because of their um
you know former situation you know with
quote unquote sexual degenerates or
whatever because they were hanging out
with aleister crowley
so at this point like uh the
relationship between
jack parsons and his uh then wife became
kind of strained
um she kind of like moved away to like
some artist commune in mexico or
whatever
so um yeah that's right they infiltrated
the irs as well you're right
yeah i think that was operations know
why it was infiltrating the irs
because the irs was going to audit that
yeah
so they got a couple people like at
low-level jobs in there that kind of
like worked their way out they ended up
bringing the irs to their knees
too about uh [ __ ] real what is it
good
because really religious taxation
remember that [ __ ] they didn't want the
religion and you know what's so much
status they eventually won they won they
brought what
they don't have to pay taxes on all of
the [ __ ] properties that they have
because now scientology is officially
seen
as a relationship religious exemption i
think is what it's called which is
[ __ ] well
actually i think all of that bullied
their way into that all of
religious exemption is [ __ ] that
should not be allowed
i mean seriously look at all the [ __ ]
property that religions
own it's a real estate scam that's what
i mean don't that should not feel like
thomas i don't know who you are
why are you back what are you what's up
okay bye see you
what what do you talk to somebody saying
goodbye
okay bye i know we've been on for so
long
well we've been going for three hours
that's good but we're almost done hour
three almost definitely
yeah so all right so at this point like
his wife has taken off
um he's been blackballed from working in
rocketry
so jack parsons decided he's gonna go
like full on back into occultism
back into his sex magic thing so he
starts recruiting uh sex workers for
that
purpose um he's basically what he wants
to do
he wants to do a ritual called the
crossing of the
abyss which i guess is
attaining union with the universal
consciousness
like you're trying to do yeah so
he says that he succeeded in doing that
which
was there any proof of that yeah but you
know what i mean
that's the nice thing about this new
agey kind of [ __ ] it's just like you
don't need any
if you just say i was going to do this
yeah
yeah yeah and everyone just has to
believe you apparently
so so he said that he did that
so then he says that he had an
out-of-body experience
that was invoked by babylon the goddess
that he had supposedly
invoked and then he was astrally
projected
back to a biblical city called
corazon tourism something's about star
wars
yeah yeah of course he's just making
this up i'm just saying
he called this the black pilgrimage okay
um yeah so
he said okay i was like i said i'm not
into all this new agey [ __ ] so every so
so excuse me if i sound a little
skeptical
dubious yeah of all this stuff so
apparently
so he goes back to this biblical city he
says that he embodied
this spirit or this entity or whatever
who is called valerian armilis
al daijal now who's saying this
jack parsons okay um who was
also the antichrist yeah
for some okay because of course this
sounds like he's been hanging out with
lrh with all this [ __ ] scientific
scientology writing like valerian
and chorus this is all from science
fiction movies that came later that's
what i mean just maybe
maybe those writers were [ __ ]
listening to all this [ __ ] like i said
i love i love fiction as much as the
next person
but you have to maintain
you can't like believe that shit's true
lrh is standing up there on the [ __ ]
deck of the free winds with all these
[ __ ] young [ __ ] cabin girls
[ __ ] listening to him at his feet
he's pointing up at the stars at night
telling them what the [ __ ] was happening
on [ __ ] distant planets on other
galaxies and [ __ ]
and where all the empires were and they
said he could go on for hours like that
and they would sit there they'd just eat
that [ __ ] up
tell them the whole star wars story
how did they not fall asleep no they
loved it it's another era
i guess yeah they didn't like have a lot
of other entertainment options basically
sit around listening to lr i'm going to
sit around on a boat and listen to some
weird
anus-mouthed man tell me what's
happening on other planets
xenu and some other [ __ ] happening on
the plants yeah
whereas at one point i'd be like
evidently they loved it
can i go read or can i get dudes they
joined the cult man they joined the cult
for a reason that's the way they were
don't know i love that [ __ ]
imagine if you like star wars and the
[ __ ] george lucas had a cult and all
you did is sit around listen to george
lucas tell you about star wars look
i love that [ __ ] look i love star wars
okay but not that much
damn you're not a real fan not so much
that i would like to listen to some
old man like talk about it like it was
real
that's what you were dealing with though
that's what i mean i don't get that
i don't do that it was another time
don't you have anything better to do
no they didn't they didn't have [ __ ]
they didn't have little [ __ ] laptop
computers and jesus
little cell phones and [ __ ] i had a
million other things i'd have to do i
didn't even see images that much you
know except the movies maybe it's tv
but the imagery sucks so everything was
imagination
again it was imagination alex says
did jenny just say anus mouth man indeed
i did yeah yeah
it's like a anus with teeth it's kind of
like that ass
judge from [ __ ] the wall remember the
movie the pinky yeah the wall movie
it's like a butthole but with the teeth
the [ __ ] yeah
he had a [ __ ] up mouth that's what all
right and then later his teeth got
[ __ ] up there were green that's what
his mouth reminds me of
he had green teeth eventually kind of
like a lamprey but also like
a butthole like a prolapsed butthole but
with teeth in it
and like when he talked like because
i've seen videos of him talking and it's
like
his lips are always like coming out and
this really looks unsettling
kind of like it's kind of like he's kind
of like [ __ ] dennis
well you have to understand maybe that's
what it is
maybe that's why because the
intergalactic warlords would all come
and descend upon us because if you
remember this because there's so many
the intergalactic you know [ __ ]
universal law enforcement
you know which is as soon as somebody
starts i'm just like bye
yeah yeah well they were all imprisoned
and it's a big [ __ ] volcano and then
they sealed it with atomic bombs and
all the thetans came out and millions of
years ago and we evolved here and
they're all inside of us now
right alien demonic possession is
exactly what he's michael schaefer says
isn't that like the movie dream catcher
probably i was you know what i couldn't
bring myself i read the book
i hated the books and was look look i
love stephen king okay
i'm just saying that right now but i
read the book dreamcatcher
and i remember i liked it it was okay
but i remember reading it and when i
finished it i said please
god that i do not believe in please do
not let anybody make a movie out of this
and they did they made a movie out of it
and from what i can discern because i'm
not gonna sit through it
um it was just as terrible as i imagined
i never saw that an adaptation of that
book would be
like look this is a prime example
of [ __ ] that works relatively well on
the page
does not work in a movie no one wants to
see
ass weasels ass weasels in a movie
there were ass weasels in the [ __ ]
book yes yeah
you see my last stephen king book was
tommy knockers i read that wow that was
a long time ago
i didn't like that book yeah i read that
and i was like this [ __ ] book i'm not
super into
aliens though as villains that's just me
that was the end of my stephen king i
think well the newest one that i read of
his was dr sleep which i actually
liked um i didn't love it um and prior
to that i think the newest one that i
had read was under the dome
okay which i actually really liked but
i promptly forgot about it after i read
it i kind of feel like
i love stephen king like i said but i
feel like his his most memorable [ __ ]
was a long time ago [ __ ] from the 70s
and 80s
and maybe 90s um the newest stuff is
good but it doesn't really like stick
with you
just like directors they have a
half-life yeah it doesn't stick with you
it's it's not that it's bad it's just
that it's not like super memorable
i couldn't give a [ __ ] about a lot of
the old directors even how great they
were back in the day but you watch them
now and flick it i'm just like nah
they don't carry any water i mean i
might have a [ __ ] camera and i'm like
man [ __ ] you
but uh look we're getting sidetracked we
gotta [ __ ] finish what else is his
name
i mean i might review some of his newer
books like on my
you know new book review show that i'm
doing but i don't know i i might or
might not because
directors and writers they age and not
necessarily like a fine wine they have
to be young
and honest yeah and honestly like um on
the new book review show that i'm doing
i'm gonna do
like some older uh [ __ ] like peter
straub
and uh maybe clyde barker and i'm gonna
do house of leaves and stuff like that
but it's like i'm kind of more
interested in exploring like newer
horror fiction because
there's a lot of um new horror writers
out nowadays that i
haven't read a lot of their stuff and i
really want to get back into it
to see what's kind of going on in you
know the present day
so it'll probably lean more toward that
but you know we'll see how it goes
so all right so at this stage um
so jack parsons he thinks that
uh you know within a few years that
babylon the goddess
the goddess is gonna manifest on earth
and supersede the dominance of the
abrahamic
religions right which remember when that
happened well they were trying to get
rid of them because they stood in the
way of their
their new religious [ __ ]
ideas that they were coming up with all
these guys
which like i said they have religions
they had to go that was kind of like i
get that like
because that was like a big thing at the
time you know the the real
they they seemed like very repressive
very backwards like i get that
um and you saw that a lot during the 60s
like people looking for other
you know spiritual paths i like
scientology's answer to the abrahamic
religions they were all just a
hallucination from
themes deatons gave you these
hallucinations they're not real only
scientology is real
which but anytime anybody tells you that
yeah
that is ultimately they're just
hallucinating that is also [ __ ]
they're just hallucinations
because that's like honestly that's kind
of one of the
if you're gonna like propagandize
particularly in a religious
sense yeah one of the first things you
do
is demonize all your competing behavior
systems
yeah that's one of the first things that
you do i mean that
is propaganda 101 yep
propaganda 101 so
uh around this time period jack parsons
also wrote
uh an essay on his
politics and his individual philosophy
um he was kind of like liberal leaning
toward libertarianism he was very
against um government interference in
anyone's private lives particularly
their sexual lives like i said he was
very
into women's equality he was very
into um i don't know if he specifically
said uh you know decriminalization of
homosexuality bisexuality but he was
very into that type of thing where
there shouldn't be any laws like
regulating like people's sexuality like
whether they have sex outside of
marriage or whether they have sex with
people of the same sex or whatever it
shouldn't be anything yeah it's
preventing orgies
right yeah so he so he was very against
that type of
[ __ ] so like i said this is 1940s he
wants to have all this girl on girl
action during the threesomes and [ __ ]
[ __ ] he wants to [ __ ] get all ages
it was [ __ ] full spectrum sexuality
that's what that's what this is all
about
yeah yeah so um so he wrote all this
stuff although
um a lot of it actually wasn't published
until uh after he
died now apparently this is one thing
when i was reading about him that kind
of i don't know why this like struck me
but apparently elrond hubbard had
written
a letter to jack parsons
telling asking him if he would take
sarah back yeah take her back and get
her the [ __ ] outta here which at that
point emerald hybrid had stolen her
yeah from john's trying to give her back
and then married her
it was like hey wander back yeah because
i'm kind of like over it
apparently you know what this is kind of
clicking with me
because with what i know of scientology
he started having problems with her
eventually
having to do with [ __ ] money and
stuff so that's probably what he's
trying to do he's trying to get rid of
her
try to get rid of her because of the
[ __ ] money and he there was a new
woman he was trying to [ __ ] pick up
too well kind of always
like like i said he was very into he had
to do with who owned what and he
i think he had some of her money and he
was trying to get rid of it's
complicated
lrh rose to power by scamming people
yeah big time yeah but
scamming people works if you look
at the dudes that become [ __ ] rich
and powerful they always start off as
two-bit [ __ ] hucksters and scabbers
they scam their way into that [ __ ] you
gotta be real good at this [ __ ] though
yeah
yeah and they [ __ ] over a lot of people
that's how they get to there
i mean you haven't once they get to a
certain amount of money now they have
something to work with but
when they're being born so to speak
they're [ __ ]
predators well they're not even
predators
there's a certain amount of honor to
being a predator they're [ __ ]
parasites
that's what they really that's a better
word they're [ __ ] parasites yeah
and like i said you can say i don't know
this is a very like fine line to walk
because when you look at people like
like look at your [ __ ] um like
televangelist let's say like from the
80s
you can say yes those people are
hucksters yes they are
exploiting a vulnerable population
you can also say you know people should
be more
savvy people should not fall for that
kind of [ __ ]
i mean but to me that seems a little bit
like victim blaming
i do feel like people like you know your
televangelists in the 80s that were
basically telling people
like i used to watch this dude like i
used to hate watch this dude
get named uh robert tilton and
yeah his big thing like he was like the
smarmiest [ __ ] ever
and like his big thing was quote unquote
give
out of your need yeah you don't have any
money
yeah but send me money and then you and
then god will reward you
and like it kind of like i was really
conflicted about it because it's like
look it makes me really sad that like
maybe some
90 year old grandma someone will fall
for that but also
why would like don't be so dumb like why
are you setting this [ __ ] armor
[ __ ] bird your money i remember when all
that was going on which is [ __ ] crazy
it's crazy i would watch that [ __ ] for a
few minutes and then just flip through
it i would thought it was amusing
but you had to ask myself that you have
to ask yourself
yeah you could look at it the two ways
you were talking about but you could
also look at it another way
was he was he offering
something that was like a service to
those people was he making them feel
better like they were going to go to
heaven
and i think in some ways they were
that's what i mean it's like you can't
it's hard to tell right because a lot of
it has to do with the emotion
and yet you don't know the situation it
could be that somebody's just terminally
ill they're gonna die
they want to go to heaven they want to
feel good so they think well if i
send him some money he'll do something
good with it
and i can die and go to heaven i'll feel
good about myself that's why i'm
confident i think a lot of it has
that's a lot of it was that because it's
like healthy normal people weren't
sending that [ __ ] money i hope
not
no no if you are if there was always
somebody
who is at the [ __ ] like i said i want
to say bottom in a barrel but
at the bottom of the food chain there's
always some at the bottom of the food
chain
but i think i think they got
gratification from it
in the same way i think it was exactly
the same thing as that home shopping
network
where you have people that are living in
trailer parks i think a lot of them are
mentally ill
buying [ __ ] trinkets over the phone
well they would call up and they would
get and they get on the show
and get attention and the woman and like
the host would talk to them
and they would buy some [ __ ]
worthless piece of freaking costume
jewelry for [ __ ] a
hundred dollars or something but they
got to grandstand for a few minutes
and they had the [ __ ] they got to talk
to them they got like a human connection
you know me being a next salesman that's
a transaction
yeah it's almost like a form of
prostitution going to a [ __ ] hooker
to get some attention
and it's over yeah money was changed
hands but without that
nothing would have happened for you yeah
you'd have been sitting there and i
think it was that same thing
to is it taking advantage of people
or is it offering a service it's very
difficult that's what i mean
it's like that's why i'm conflicted
about it because in some ways it's like
yes they are taking advantage of a
vulnerable population
yeah but also those people
are adults yeah i mean unless they have
like mental issues obviously that's a
different thing but it's like
are they getting something out of it
that's worth it i think they are
right and it did it would not surprise
me if you were to go back to the records
of those televangelists
and see that it's it's not one
that it's regular customers over and
over again i'm sure it is i'm sure
they're getting a gratification out of
it somehow
i mean to me like me watching it like
hate watching it
yeah i was just kind of like why the
[ __ ] would anybody because it seemed
like so obvious to me
that this dude was just like yeah send
me your [ __ ] money
you stupid you know yes
you stupid rube well that's how i was
interpreting it because that's how it
sounded to me
and then you're looking at it through
the looking at it through your rational
eyes
well obviously you're not looking at it
through the eyes of a person that's
[ __ ] doing it right right
and they're seeing this guy as an
ambassador to god
in heaven and they're going to die and
they're going to heaven
it's it's a very different dynamic and
there's a certain
i'm convinced because i've seen the old
ladies that were doing that kind of [ __ ]
they were into that because i know the
type
they had them all over mississippi
living in [ __ ] trailers all right
they were magical thinkers yeah all
right
so i understand why they're doing it i
understand it too it's just
and i don't believe that they actually
100 believed it either
like i'm in the back of their mind they
knew that they were getting
gratification from it
and that they and i think there was the
doubt that
yeah i like doing it because i'm a part
of something
you know what i mean i'm gonna give them
some they're trying to help
yeah basically what they're trying to do
yeah they're helping that dude
they've been you know what i mean
they're helping him that's all there and
that's all they're helping really
but he had a whole organization why are
we sidetracked we're [ __ ] sidetracked
again we're talking about televangelists
how do you do that to me sidetrack me
that it is it is an interesting
topic we ought to get into those
[ __ ] i honestly have had like
televangelists and stuff on my list for
like a really long time
and to you foreign listeners they don't
exist anymore that's gone that era
is gone i don't think so i mean like
several years
ago i know there were a few channels
like like they would be on youtube they
wouldn't be on television if they
existed
i don't know man because old people
still watch tv
maybe i think there are a couple of
channels like i don't know
because i don't watch tv but it's like i
mean there might be some channels
i think i mean several like 10 years ago
there were still channels that were
dedicated to that
yeah but i don't know right now it's not
like
even back in the 80s when i was a kid to
me it was
obvious that it was a show yeah it was
obvious that it was a show
it was obvious to me that these dudes
had a rock star type
[ __ ] persona to them when all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] about them with the
tammy faye and the [ __ ] chick with
the big old titties and [ __ ] what was
her name
okay one didn't end up in the chat she
ended up being in
she was like jessica yeah yeah she ended
up being why do i remember
he ended up being
but to me that was not even shocking i
was like well of course that's what that
was
it's obvious to me what that that's what
that was yeah well that
that was you know i don't understand why
people were shocked well see
that's what i'm that's what that was and
it's what it always was that's what i'm
saying
is that coming from somebody even when i
was even growing up in the 80s when i
was
a teenager yeah i knew i would watch
that [ __ ] and i'd be like that's
obviously
yeah hawksters yeah and the fact that
anyone would take that
seriously or the fact that anyone would
be surprised
when for example like one of them would
come out and it's like oh they had a
stash of child porn or one of them would
come out like they would do porn later
it's like why would anybody be shocked
by that that's like i don't know why
anybody'd be shocked by that to me
as a young guy coming out of a [ __ ]
heavy metal background i
instantly [ __ ] recognize that as a
[ __ ] rock concert for old ladies
yeah that you have a guy up there and
maybe a [ __ ] older woman that they
can identify with putting on a show
that they're both sex symbols that
they're both [ __ ] making money and
giving entertainment
i obviously understood what that was and
then the fact you got jessica han and
[ __ ] all this stuff
of course that [ __ ] would be going on of
course
that's what it was can i just tell you
rock can i just tell you right now
religious heavy metal if
in that old lady direction and i'm
watching like televangelists and
like home shopping it won't be nice
anymore please
shoot me it won't happen it won't happen
anymore it was only
that generation and they're dead now i
hope so that was my oh my god
seriously if that happens to me you will
know that i have lost my [ __ ] mind
that was that was my grandmother's
generation yeah
they're they're all dead now
you know if there's some out there
that's very few of them
look at zach what's zach saying hey guys
i just got home from work how much of
the show did i miss
almost three and a half hours you missed
the blob fish you missed
all the porn you missed all kind
l ron hubbard scientology you missed all
that stuff
tammy stumbo is saying that they're on
tv and her mother-in-law loves them i
told you that's still
that much some weird [ __ ] because that
was most that was some [ __ ] out of my
grandmother's channel people still watch
tv
we don't they have to know that that
shit's fake i mean i'm old too [ __ ] dude
i'm almost 50.
you're well you're 51. i would have been
old a long time ago
back when you only lived to be about 50.
i still got another you'd be dead by now
i'd be dead but i got a 25 i probably
would love you too
i will be [ __ ] artificially pickled
and [ __ ]
preserved in tequila the tequila
anabolic steroids keeping me i'll be
like jack lalanne
96 years old i'm hoping that all the
alcohol will pickle me
i'm kind of hoping that you know what i
mean
yeah i mean i feel like i'm almost
filmed like i'll be 48 in september
and i'm kind of hoping that
i'll kind of says that she's in her 70s
yeah that makes a little bit more sense
that's my mother's
generation they might be a little bit
susceptible
to me i i don't think they even 100
take it seriously i think they i think
they know it's entertainment they're
just trying to be a part of a crowd that
believes in something and they're trying
to do something
it's i think it's more of a substitute
for a scene you know what i mean it's
like
like a and i think it was kind of like
that back then
because it was it was old women in their
70s
you know everybody wants to join
something why do they want to do that
in in mississippi it was older women in
their 70s that were into that [ __ ]
back in the tammy faye era yeah i know
and they were living by themselves their
husbands were dead
and they'd watch that [ __ ] and it was
just like it's a big singing along like
a happy clappy
and they'd send some money because they
wanted to see the show again but they
didn't and i
i don't think they realized that it was
a [ __ ] fest behind the scenes and that
they had helicopters and whole [ __ ]
huge compounds
that the [ __ ] owned small towns
you know what i mean
they [ __ ] huge comp religious
compounds you know with
big titty [ __ ] secretaries with it
that were ready to shoot porn
i don't think they thought that but to
me i was
i was i was thinking that that's exactly
what it was well because he came out
here's the thing all these
televangelists particularly and like i
said we need to do a whole show on this
yeah i can i could go on for hours
but honestly the [ __ ] that people
go on the most about like or they
condemn the most
that's what they're doing that's what
they're doing because that's proof
it's universal protection that's
projection i mean look at like the i
can't remember the dude's name
john what was his name john tanner he
was some kind of like um
government dude in florida back in the
80s or 90s
and all he was doing was just hammering
on porn porn pornhorn and i was sitting
there going that dude
they're gonna find that his house is
full of porn guess what
his house was full of porn oh yeah
because why the [ __ ] would you care
otherwise it's just kind of like all
these dudes that go on about
oh the gays and oh this that and the
other that's always a gay dude
it's always somebody that has had or
it's not necessarily a gay dude but it's
somebody that's had gay feelings and
ashamed of it or some [ __ ] like that
it's always something like that because
otherwise why would you care what other
people are doing
they're focusing in on why would you
care it's like i don't care what other
people are doing there but i'm getting
sidetracked we're getting
inside my business so it's like the fact
that they're so focused on it
means that they must have some personal
stake in that they're focused in on it
because they're focused on it
right yeah so yeah i'm just saying
that's what i'm not saying that
everybody that is like
they caught a lot of those anti-gay is
gay but i'm just saying that they may
have had like a crush on a dude and like
they're ashamed about it
and they can't deal with it and so the
televangelists that i remember that got
busted
were with [ __ ] dudes yeah i'm just
saying that's not always the case but
you know what i mean that's usually i
remember two or three of those going
down
because that's like a big hotel room
that's a big thing that you do
when you repress your own feelings you
tend to
project onto others like
your own shame you project it onto other
people
and i think they don't realize that it's
very obvious to other people that that's
exactly what they're doing
oh pookie came in the door creeped okay
so for a while so jack parsons works for
uh i believe howard hughes aviation
company
so but he gets fired from there because
yeah because of all the
fbi uh attention around him because of
his
activities um so what they thought that
he was doing
which i don't think there was really any
evidence for but he had taken
some of the um like
it wasn't like real sensitive material
or anything but he had taken some
documents from there and he'd copied
them
and he sent them like overseas because
he was trying to get a job
in israel because he'd been blackballed
in the u.s there's pookie
she's gonna be on the show for a second
until she's be like [ __ ] off
so um because he'd been blackballed from
working in
uh rocketry jet propulsion whatever you
want to call it in the u.s so he was
looking for a job overseas
in that field so he was going to move to
israel and work in israel
so he was like copying some of the
documents
like to go along with his resume and
one of the secretaries at the company
like i guess
saw him doing that or knew that he did
that and knocked on him
and so the fbi like kind of swooped in
and investigated him again for being a
spy
for the israeli government but they kind
of
like they did like some investigations
and they found that they didn't
there wasn't really any cause for that
and even the [ __ ] that he copied wasn't
like secretive material or anything
um it was just him being dumb and not
really thinking about the optics of it
um but you know they still did consider
him a liability because
like i said he'd once like been a
marxist and blah blah
so he still gets a ban uh in 1952
uh from working on classified projects
so he gets um so what he does
he basically has to start his own
company at this point because he's been
blackballed from working in the industry
he starts his own company called the
parsons chemical manufacturing company
based in north hollywood and what that
was doing
was he was working on explosives
pyrotechnics fog effects stuff like that
for the film industry
so he was started working on the movies
because they wouldn't let him work on
rockets anymore because of whatever
so what ends up happening at this point
like so he he's running that business he
also
has a home lab uh which he's you know
established in his house like in the
laundry room
which he's working as chemical stuff he
also is making home brew
absinthe nice um he also
like started renting out like some of
the you know rooms in his house and
stuff like to make extra money
so what he also started like another
felima group which he called the
witchcraft so he was still into that as
well
um so apparently he gets
a job working on
um a hollywood film like a film set
that it was gonna be like an explosion
so this is in june of 1952.
and he gets uh the job and it's like a
rush
they're like look we need these like
explosive special effects we need you to
do it like right away because we're
really behind
so he starts working on it in his home
lab
and for whatever reason
um he
blew himself up okay that's
about the only way that we can say it so
it
the explosion like destroyed the lower
part of his house
um basically his right
forearm was blown off damn half of his
face
was torn off um
and you know what i mean like so and
like he had broken arms broken legs it's
like it just blew him the [ __ ] up
damn he looked like dav ross from
[ __ ] the doctor who
yeah or you know like [ __ ] anakin
skywalker yeah
something like that like he got all his
[ __ ] blown off now this
the [ __ ] up thing is that
when they found him he was still
conscious yeah like he could still talk
and stuff
so he tries to like so the ambulance
comes and he's trying to still talk to
them and [ __ ]
and you know he couldn't really say
anything coherent
i mean obviously so they take him to the
hospital
a little more than half an hour later
he's pronounced dead
okay 37 years old damn
dad young he did now
there are a lot of shitty things about
this okay the first shitty thing about
this is that
as soon as he died as soon as his
mom heard about him dying she took an
overdose and killed herself
damn so she did it on purpose or by
accident
uh on purpose okay yeah it was a suicide
now okay now
probably his death was ruled
an accident like he was mixing up some
chemicals to do an explosion for a movie
set
and people are like oh he was mixing up
stuff in a coffee can
and it slipped out of his hands he
dropped it and it mixed with some other
[ __ ] that was on the floor or like
whatever
and it blew the [ __ ] up now
that's the official story um not crazy
because a lot of his friends said yeah
he was real clumsy he wasn't super
careful
like his hands were always sweaty so he
could have like just dropped the can
some of his other friends have
speculated
that because this was very early in the
cold war he was very inconvenient
i mean he'd been someone that was kind
of on the forefront of
you know rocketry of like starting the
jet propulsion laboratory
and he was inconvenient in the sense
that he was kind of a leftist he was
kind of he was into the occult
and he was a little bit quote-unquote
embarrassing so it would have been to
the government's
benefit to have him disappear
so some people have said that perhaps
this was murder sounds very far-fetched
i don't know if i buy that
um i do it i kind of feel like
maybe it was maybe an accident some
people said oh probably wasn't an
accident because he was really good at
mixing chemicals blah blah blah
but even people that are really good at
mixing chemicals can still make a
mistake or they can still drop something
really
just working on a movie probably wasn't
taking it too seriously and some people
have said too that it might have been
suicide that it might have been
deliberate suicide because he had been
having problems with depression prior to
he'd been going through a lot of [ __ ]
like the epi i was watching him
he'd uh lost his wife he lost his job
so there was like a lot of bad [ __ ] that
was going on in his life so
it could have been either one or the
other do i think that
he was deliberately murdered i doubt it
i mean it does seem weird like the
timing of it
but i don't think that's enough evidence
to say because it could have been an
accident or it could have been
deliberately
suicide i think those are more likely as
me
he thought the work was beneath him he
wasn't taking it [ __ ] too serious
yeah he made him
and he might have been rushing because
like it was a rush job he's like man i'm
just doing this [ __ ] and it was just for
a movie
yeah right because you have to think
that this was
i mean he was a genius and he had been
working for
you know grumman aeronautics he had been
working for jpl he had been working like
in these high
ranking kind of positions and then
because
of the [ __ ] that he was doing outside of
work
he thought that she was beneath it he
got fired and blackballed
so it might have been and he kind of got
forced into starting his own business
working in the movies so he might have
thought it was [ __ ]
yeah like you said i think and he wasn't
really like he wasn't taking the job
seriously right he wasn't really at the
top of his game
right um i'm not i don't think that it's
completely out of bounds to say it was
suicide either i mean because
like i said many of his uh friends and
family said that he was he had been
depressed
which wasn't crazy like you know
considering all that it happened
depression doesn't mean suicide he may
have been depressed
because he was in what he thought was a
shitty job that was beneath him
he wasn't really taking the job too
seriously he was kind of rushing through
it
boom blew himself up yeah that's what i
think happened
but that's like that's crazy that that
[ __ ] happened i've done [ __ ] like
that [ __ ]
trying to rush through jobs that i
didn't think were seriously in the
series and [ __ ] them up
didn't blow myself up but [ __ ] up what
i was working
it's like on the job you know well and i
feel like
and i feel like like i said i'm not a
big believer in conspiracy theories i
feel like you need to have a lot of
evidence to support that kind of [ __ ]
because people are just people they make
mistakes
even people that are really accomplished
like yes he was very good at mixing
explosive
yes he did know a lot about chemistry
yes he did
but everybody can make a mistake
everybody can drop something
everybody can like their hand can slip
or they can trip or something like that
that can happen to anybody so i don't
think just that
is enough to say an assassination is not
a conspiracy theory
an assassination is an assassination
right was this guy assassinated no
he wasn't a high value target no
he'd have been he was out of the game
there's no reason to kill him
you know what i mean yeah if he's he's a
communist so the fbi is going to kill
him he's out of the game he's not doing
anything important he's working for the
[ __ ] movies
and the thing he was like that dude i
feel like it would be
more in the line of
the fbi of the government to more like
discredit him yeah
because they would probably think like
oh well he was into like
sex magic and like you know i they
should probably play that up yeah
because then if he talked nobody would
believe him assassinating somebody's
called wet work
and really the fp the cia or the fbi or
the kgb
intel agencies they did that as a
as i think a last resort they didn't
have to do that
like you said it's easier to discredit
somebody or to ignore something yeah to
just say that they're like a lunatic
yeah
that's much easier so much easier to
like [ __ ] up their income or to plant a
[ __ ] pilgrim story about them you
know it's just
killing them really it's
counterproductive
because it [ __ ] it attracts too much
attention yeah like you said it's like
that would seem like the the ultimate
last resort it's the last resort
so whenever somebody and i'm not saying
they don't kill people because they've
got like the
the child island man that did not kill
himself it was the last resort
he was in custody well yeah but killed
that dude though
but like i said i feel like it's so much
easier to just
and particularly with jack parsons
because and i'm not saying that he
brought it on himself because obviously
he didn't
but because he had such unconventional
beliefs it would have been very easy
to discredit him in the eyes of the
public
in the way that no one would listen to
him
because they just thought he was a loon
so
why go to the trouble of killing him of
potentially getting caught or
potentially getting in trouble he wasn't
working on anything important anyway he
wasn't
well yeah at this point he had been
blackballed
yeah um and he wasn't working i mean he
had started his own company he was just
working
in the movies he wasn't working on any
military yes he did know some secrets
about the [ __ ]
which is why some people still thought
that he was murdered because he did know
a lot of the [ __ ] because he was in you
know he was in on the ground floor
essentially
of nasa because he was right there like
you know in the early days of like them
developing the rockets and stuff
that wouldn't have been important but i
do feel like by the time that he
died um i feel like that
information probably would have been so
widely disseminated that it wasn't
really
that there wasn't anything that he would
have known that wouldn't have been known
by someone else maybe
is you know what i'm saying i'm not
saying it didn't happen i'm just saying
it's unlikely
usually when they knock somebody off it
has nothing to do with what they know in
terms of technology it's what they know
about a certain powerful person that
they don't want to come out
it usually has to do with possible
criminal charges against somebody else
that's usually what
what happens yeah and this is not a new
phenomenon there were dudes that got
knocked off or suspected to get knocked
off all the way back in the 70s
they had a dude who was a reporter who
was trying to
he he was wanted to write a book i think
it was called the octopus and he
he had a theoretical he had a
theoretical situation where
government military and [ __ ]
corporations and organized crime a place
in which they would all
meet in other words you know what i mean
a place where
powerful men or an organ you know what i
mean that powerful men were doing
[ __ ] bad things with organized crime
and government what he's talking about
is what you would call a day like
the deep state well he was found dead
[ __ ] in a hotel bathtub that was on
unsolved mysteries
he was right he was writing a book about
it
it was 70s wasn't it 70s or 80s as far
as that yeah
it never [ __ ] resolved that case well
he was asking [ __ ]
questions and that can happen
you know did he kill himself or did
somebody kill him because they made it
look like a suicide
it's but that's what intel agencies do
they make things look
ambiguous yeah when they get you
well this guy blowing himself up is not
very ambiguous if they were to kill him
they would kill him another way
although you could argue that if they
were gonna kill him
that seemed like the best way to kill
him because that would be the way that
would be most likely to look like an
accident because that was the line of
work that he was in i would say and he
was always blowing [ __ ] up
i would say they would have killed him
with a drug overdose or an alcohol hall
overdose because he did do that or they
would hit him with a car
something like that or they would have
run his car off the road
something like that something a lot less
dramatic
something that could be like well he was
drunk he did that yeah
because that's usually what they do yeah
they run you off they run you off roads
and they crash your car you know
which i don't know like i don't know how
i feel about it it's kind of like
like i said you know were there reasons
they would have wanted him dead
probably but not enough not enough
to and i kind of feel like because he
worked with
explosive chemicals all the time because
that was his line of work
um it would be very easy to just like
slip
up one time and and the thing is you
work in explosives
you slip up one time you're dead
so i don't know so i so i feel like
there's not really enough evidence
i know some some of his friends do feel
like they killed him
because and honestly certainly the fbi
did watch him
from the 1940s they admitted that later
on he was under surveillance by
and um you know he had said that he
thought he was under surveillance and
they thought he was nuts but he actually
was they admitted that later
um so i get that he was under
surveillance he was under suspicion
for being a spy for being a marxist for
being whatever
but you know was it enough to kill him
at this late stage
i doubt it i i kind of feel like it was
probably just an accident or
maybe it was suicide could have been
because he did
i mean his dad um
did suffer from depression did suffer
from those types of like mental issues
and he might have inherited those
so i do feel like there might be some
and like i said he had gone through a
lot of [ __ ] in his life like losing his
wife losing his job blahdy blah
so it might have been a kind of thing
where he just said [ __ ] it i'm out
um but do i think he was murdered
i doubt it no i doubt it it's not
impossible but i doubt it
no yeah there's not enough there now
it's it's interesting because i feel
like for a while
because the weird thing about jack
parsons is that
even though he was like this monumental
figure
in founding the jet propulsion
laboratory which is like the basis of
nasa
and he was like a huge figure in rocket
science
and you know the the propulsion systems
the [ __ ] they used to get to the moon
even though he didn't live to see it
sadly so even though he was like
instrumental in that i feel like they
were kind of embarrassed of him for a
long time because of the occult [ __ ]
yeah because so like
nasa like well he was a young dude too
he was he was only 37 when he died
so so nasa like they named a crater on
the moon after him
yeah but it was a crater that was like
on the dark side yeah yeah okay
so it was always kind of like i liked it
though probably i yeah it's like i kind
of feel like he would have thought that
was amusing
but in some ways like in hindsight you
can see that it's just like oh well
you want to like say that it's like oh
awesome but we're gonna like hide you
over here so you know what i mean it did
kind of seem like that
yeah but it does seem like in the past
few years he's kind of got
a little bit of a renaissance like i
said in uh i believe it was 2014
please correct me if i'm wrong could
have been earlier but there was a book
that came out called strange angel which
was about him
and there was actually a um series that
was based off
of that it was fictionalized but it was
based on his life and it's on
uh cbs all access uh you know the
streaming service and they did two
seasons of it which i believe was 2017
and 2018
which was also called strange angel and
it was about him i haven't seen it but
i've
heard it was pretty decent i'd like to
read the book as well because he seems
like a really fascinating
character but you know so it does seem
like in the last few years there's been
like a new appreciation of him
and honestly when i when i search
youtube
for [ __ ] about this guy it seems like
he's
almost better known for the occult [ __ ]
than he is for the rocket science [ __ ]
and i'm not really sure how to feel
about that you know what i'm saying
it's like i feel like everyone's into
like oh he was into like
felima and all that but they kind of
forget about it and i think people are
just kind of fixated on him because
he was into both rockets and [ __ ] the
occult because that is
unusual he knew lrh he blew himself up
that's that's really what it's all about
but he was an interesting guy who was a
young guy
you know yeah they were experimental
dudes this was cutting edge [ __ ]
and uh his interpretation of the
paranormal was like [ __ ] quantum
quantum physics and quantum theory which
is actually that kind of lines up with
some of the [ __ ] that i believe the
[ __ ]
with [ __ ] you know poltergeist in the
quantum soul theory and stuff
yeah so but you can put quantum in front
of anything and sound [ __ ] special
nobody knows what it is there's just
there's just
more [ __ ] to science than what we
know science is just a tool we don't
understand everything yet
i mean i feel like my mind has an
ability to [ __ ] somehow
[ __ ] with reality kind of like
schrodinger's cat you know what i mean
uh perception has something to do with
it well i mean i feel like i see reality
is like this big
impenetrable mountain and you're just
kind of like
chipping away at it like a little bit at
a time yeah like
you know we know a lot more than we did
like a hundred years ago 200 years ago
but we still have like a long way to go
reality might not be as real as we think
it is it might be a holographic
kind of reality you know there's a bunch
of different theories
here's the thing though like i'm kind of
like
i've read a lot of [ __ ] about this whole
like the whole matrix thing like maybe
everything's a hologram
but even if it was like what
what would the point of that be like
what action could we take
i think they're just would there be any
like
i think what they're just talking about
practical application
of knowing that information yeah you
might be able to cheat you might be able
to cheat space and time
you might be able to cheat [ __ ] mass
and energy you know
the uh what what they're saying is that
mass and energy may not be as real as
you think it is
or you might affect the reality of mass
and energy you know like what makes a
particle have mass
is there another is there some kind of
little subatomic particle that makes
a [ __ ] atom have mass can you get rid
of that particle and make mass massless
you know it's this is all [ __ ] that
they're doing me and you can't do it we
don't have particle colliders and
accelerators and [ __ ] and and you know
it's a [ __ ] very complicated
science and they still don't know
everything yet
so that's what honestly that's one of
the things that frustrates me the most
is that
i'm kind of one of those people it's
like i want to know like
all the [ __ ] and i feel like too much
weird [ __ ] that's what i mean i will
never know all the [ __ ] i'll die before
they figure this out you know there
there's
that's a bummer you think that that a
piece of matter can only be in
one place at a time and it's not true
something can bi-locate
that that a subatomic particle can be in
two different places at the same time
they've proven it you know even though
it's a sub
it's a it's just a [ __ ] atom that's
what i mean reality is like so
so you know and what that means is and
then there's [ __ ] spooky action at a
distance which you know they don't
really understand that
distance or in other words space may not
be as real as you think it is
at least and they know there are also
higher dimensions and there are more
dimensions and that the universe
possibly came from the collapse of
[ __ ] dimensions
and i'ma let them worry about it i don't
know i kind of like hope that i live
long enough to like for them to figure
some of this [ __ ] out
it means that eventually they might be
able to make [ __ ] like any gravity or
they might be able to make
[ __ ] like teleportation or they might
i'm holding out for teleportation well
they might be able to make things like
time travel
maybe only into the future i doubt the
past but maybe in the future
you know what i mean like wants to go to
the past anyway i don't
well if you went to the past you could
change things that might be interesting
that's interesting
so you know there's a bunch of [ __ ] that
you might be able to figure out
free energy or cheating and getting
energy out of nothing
a bunch of different for some reason the
thing that i am most into
is teleportation people we need to get
on teleportation
that would [ __ ] revolutionize
everything yeah and ever since i was a
kid
i was like yeah we need to figure out
how to do that
all right so let's shut the show down
ready to shut it down
have we really been going all the way
around four years yeah
four years four years it only feels like
four years
it only feels like four years because i
had tequila instead of vodka and i'm
just like
in a way that was good because it made
me drink it slower because
it tastes funny yeah you know what i
mean
okay kind of aslan says
i need a sports almanac yeah
i know all right so we've been going on
almost four hours we're probably both
super
inebriated so go ahead and shut this
down jane
all right so we hope you enjoyed the
show about
jack parsons which was mostly about jack
parsons i think
i mean from what i can remember it was
about everything
that's what the show is you just get
information on every conceivable topic
even when you weren't even expecting
that
so uh hopefully you guys enjoyed it
thank you all for stopping by thanks
everyone for their donations and
remember
if you like the show please like share
subscribe on all your social media
uh if you'd like to contribute to the
show
uh please drop by our patreon page
patreon.com
13 o'clock podcast and uh we give like
early access
to some of the shows like [ __ ] movie
reviews and
various things of that nature um or you
can give a donation through paypal if
you would like to do that
and uh that'll do it for episode 207
the hurricane has not hit us yet no
we'll see how it's going it's only
8 47 p.m yep so it might
hit sometime at night we might get hit
by a tornado but uh
anyway we'll see you guys uh probably
tomorrow we'll probably live stream
tomorrow
gonna do a movie review tomorrow so uh
we'll see you guys
tomorrow bye
oh man that's